Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. From early morning workouts that need a boost to late night drives that need vibes, a good playlist can help you make the most out of your everyday. And when it comes to everyday spending, you can count on the PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. With the best playlists, you never miss a good song. With this card, you never miss out on getting the most points on everyday purchases.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。从需要注入活力的清晨锻炼，到需要氛围感的深夜驾驶，一份优质的歌单能帮您充分利用日常生活的每一刻。而在日常消费方面，您可以信赖 PC Insider's World Elite 万事达卡，它能帮您在每一次购物时赚取最多的 PC Optimum 积分。拥有最棒的歌单，您就不会错过任何一首好歌。有了这张卡，您在日常消费中也绝不会错过赚取最多积分的机会。
The PC Insider's World Elite MasterCard, the card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit pcfinancial.ca for details. The all new, all electric Can-Am Pulse Motorcycle is your cheat code for the city. Light, agile, and stylish for all you smart commuters. Find your pulse today. Learn more at canammotorcycles.com. Learn more at canammotorcycles.com
PC Insider's World Elite 万事达卡，开启无限生活的信用卡。各项福利均受相关条款约束。详情请访问 pcfinancial.ca。全新纯电动加长骑行（Can-Am Pulse）摩托车是您的城市作弊码。轻巧、灵活、时尚，专为所有聪明的通勤者打造。今天就来寻找您的心跳（pulse）。了解更多信息，请访问 canammotorcycles.com。了解更多信息，请访问 canammotorcycles.com
In spring, the dawn, when the slowly-paling mountain rim is tinged with red and wisps of faintly crimson-purple cloud float in the sky. In summer, the night. Moonlit nights, of course, but also at the dark of the moon. It's beautiful when fireflies are dancing everywhere in a mazy flight. And it's delightful, too, to see just one or two fly through the darkness, glowing softly. Rain falling on a summer night is also lovely. In autumn, the evening, the blazing sun has sunk very close to the mountain rim, and now
春天是破晓时分，渐渐发白的群山边缘泛着红晕，微红紫色的云彩飘浮在天空中。夏天是夜晚。当然是月夜，但即使是没有月亮的黑夜也很美。到处都是萤火虫在迷宫般的飞行中翩翩起舞，这景象非常美丽。看到一两只萤火虫穿过黑暗，柔和地发光，也同样令人愉快。夏夜下雨也是很迷人的。秋天是傍晚，耀眼的太阳沉到非常靠近群山边缘的地方，现在
even the crows in threes and fours or twos and threes hurrying to their roost are a moving sight. Still more enchanting is the sight of a string of wild geese in the distant sky, very tiny. And oh, how inexpressible when the sun has sunk to hear in the growing darkness the wind and the song of autumn insects. In winter, the early morning, if snow is falling of course, it's unutterably delightful. But it's perfect too if there's a pure white frost or even just when it's very cold and they hasten to build up the fires and the braziers and carry in fresh
甚至连三三两两或两两三三急着回巢的乌鸦，也是一幅动人的景象。更让人着迷的是，远空中排成一行的大雁，显得十分渺小。哦，当太阳落山时，在越来越浓的夜色中听到风声和秋虫的鸣叫，那种感觉真是无法用言语形容。冬天的清晨，如果正在下雪，当然是妙不可言。但如果有纯白的霜，甚至仅仅是很冷的时候，人们急忙生火、搭起火盆、搬进新鲜的
charcoal. But it's unpleasant as the day draws on and the air grows warmer how the brazier fire dies down to white ash. So that, ladies and gentlemen, is one of the most famous passages in all Japanese literature. I would argue one of the most extraordinary passages of prose you will ever read. It is the beginning of a really, really remarkable and original masterpiece called The Pillow Book, which was written in the early years of the 11th century in what is now Kyoto. And Tom, we talked last time about the great Japanese classic, The Tale of Genji.
木炭，也是完美无比的。不过，随着白天气温升高，空气变暖，火盆里的火漸漸变成白灰，这就让人感到有些不快了。女士们先生们，这就是日本文学中最著名的篇章之一。我认为这也是你读过的最非凡的散文篇章之一。这是一部真正非凡且极具原创性的杰作的开端，名为《枕草子》，它写于 11 世纪初的平安京（今京都）。汤姆，我们上次谈到了日本的伟大古典名著《源氏物语》。
This was written round about the same time in what was then called Heian-kyo. And as with The Tale of Genji, its author was a woman. Yes. The woman was called say Shonagon and Murasaki Shikibu, the author of The Tale of Genji, knew Seishonagon and didn't like her. So she wrote in her diary, Seishonagon was dreadfully conceited. She thought herself so clever and littered her writings with Chinese characters. But if you examine them closely, they left a great deal to be desired. So like a kind of negative review of our podcast.
这部作品大约写于同一时期，当时的京城被称为平安京。正如《源氏物语》一样，它的作者是一位女性。是的。这位女性名叫清少纳言（Sei Shonagon），而《源氏物语》的作者紫式部（Murasaki Shikibu）认识清少纳言，并且不喜欢她。因此她在日记中写道：清少纳言狂妄自大得可怕。她自作聪明，文章中夹杂着汉字。但如果你仔细检查它们，就会发现它们有诸多不足。这简直就像是对我们播客的某种负面评价。
Left by the hosts of an inferior Goalhanger podcast. No doubt. Although of course, I mean, you know, Murasaki and Saishonogun are both transcendent geniuses. Right. So it's actually the analogy doesn't work at all. It breaks down there. Yeah. So I think what you get there is a clear tone of envy. I mean, you know, we've got certain tones of envy. We are, I
由一个劣质的 Goalhanger 播客的主持人留下的。毫无疑问。尽管当然了，我的意思是，你知道的，紫式部和清少纳言都是超越时代的天才。对吧。所以实际上这个类比根本行不通。到这里就破产了。是的。所以我想你在那里能感受到一种明显的嫉妒语气。我的意思是，你知道的，我们身上也有某些嫉妒的语气。我想这其实并不奇怪，因为这两位女性在很多方面都相当相似。所以说清少纳言的“清”是一个家族姓氏，但是纳言（Shonagon）就像式部（Shikibu）一样，所以紫式部的所谓“第二个名字”其实是日本古代宫廷文官体制中的一个官职名称。因此，就像紫式部、清少纳言是一位官员、公务员的女儿。紫式部之所以知道清少纳言，是因为她们都曾在宫廷里担任过某种类似于女官的职务，侍奉过一位皇后。而且就像紫式部一样，清少纳言也懂汉语。我们在上一集里讨论过，在当时，一个女人懂汉语被认为是非常没有女性风范、非常不得体的。紫式部曾试图掩饰自己懂汉语这件事
guess it's not surprising actually, because the two women are in lots of ways quite alike. So say Shonagon say is a family name, but Shonagon like Shikibu, so Murasaki's kind of second name is the name of a post in the Imperial Civil Service. So likeagon like Shikibu, so Murasaki's kind of second name, is the name of a post in the Imperial civil service. So like Murasaki, Shikibu, say Shonagon is the daughter of a functionary, of a civil servant. And Murasaki knew about say Shonagon because they had both served as kind of ladies in waiting to an empress in the Imperial court. And also like Murasaki, Sae Shonigan knew Chinese. We talked about this in the previous episode that for a woman to know Chinese seen as very un-ladylike, very unbecoming. And Murasaki tried to keep her knowledge of Chinese
你知道的，她对此感到很尴尬。身边的其他女官也为此取笑她。但清少纳言并没有掩饰。她完全是在炫耀自己对汉语的知识。她一点也不害怕展现自己的才华。而且她以如此优雅和富有魅力的风格做到这一点，这显然使她成为了宫廷里的一颗巨星。因此，与紫式部不同，她毫不掩饰自己随时准备站出来成为全场焦点的意愿。因此她在《枕草子》中写道：我并不以谦逊或谨慎而闻名。所以再次回到清少纳言（她不以谦逊闻名）与《历史的余烬》主持人的对比，这在某种程度上就说不通了，对吧，汤姆？
secret. You know, she was embarrassed by it. Her fellow ladies in waiting teased her about it. But Seishonagun did not veil it. She absolutely paraded her knowledge of Chinese. She's absolutely unafraid to make a show of her brilliance. And she does it with such style and charisma that it clearly makes her a massive star at court. So unlike Murasaki, she boasts of how ready she is to kind of stand up and be the centre of attention. So she writes in the Pillow Book, I am not renowned for my modesty or prudence. So again, the comparison between Shea Shonigan, who's not renowned for her modesty and the presenters of the rest is history, that rather breaks down there, doesn't it, Tom?
我们非常害羞内向，就像紫式部一样。完全正确。现在，当我们上次解释《源氏物语》以及这种 9、10、11 世纪日本的世界时，我们曾讨论过这是一本多么非凡的读物。我必须说，在许多方面，我认为《枕草子》甚至更加非凡。所以我过去几天一直在阅读它。每一页上闪耀着的光芒，都是机智、才华、老练、魅力以及
We're very shy and retiring like Murasaki. Exactly. Now we talked last time when we were explaining about The Tale of Genji and this world of kind of 9th, 10th, 11th century Japan. We sort of talked about what a remarkable book it is to read. And I have to say in many ways I think the Pillow Book is even more remarkable. So I've been reading it over the last few days. And what shines through on every page is the wit, the brilliance, the sophistication, the charm and the individual personality of
作者独特的个性，这种程度是我在任何其他中世纪文学作品中从未遇到过的。我的意思是，这真的是清少纳言的书，当你阅读它时，你会觉得你认识她，这种感觉是你在当时的任何其他作家身上都感受不到的。我的意思是，我想不出任何古代或中世纪的文学作品，其中魅力和机智正如你所说，在每一页上都显露无遗。我的意思是，这并不是你真正与古代文学联系在一起的东西。正如你所说，她的个性是如此生动，以至于你觉得你完全认识她。我同意，就像《源氏物语》一样，它让人感觉有些错位。你必须不断地掐自己一下，提醒
the author in a way that I don't think I've ever encountered with any other work of medieval literature. I mean, this really is, say, Shonigan's book and you feel like you know her when you're reading it in a way you don't with any other author at the time. I mean, I can't think of any work of ancient or medieval literature where charm and wit, as you say, is manifest on every page. I mean, it's not what you associate really with kind of ancient literature. And as you say, her personality is so vivid that you feel like you completely know her. And I agree that like the tale of Genji, it feels dislocating. You have to keep pinching yourself and reminding
自己这是一个正在写作的人，你知道的，我一直在英国重复这句话，这是盎格鲁-撒克逊时期。我的意思是，这太神奇了。那么她是怎么开始写这本书的呢？因为这本身就是一个非凡的故事。是的，而且很可能是编造的。所以这也是阅读《枕草子》的乐趣之一，那就是清少纳言非常、非常调皮。我认为你永远不能完全相信她所说的话。所以“枕草子”这个名字，来自于她如何开始写这本书的故事。她给出的故事是一个大臣来到皇后（也就是清少纳言的女主人）那里，向皇后呈上一大叠纸。皇后
yourself this is someone who's writing, you know, keep saying this in England, this is the Anglo-Saxon period. I mean, it is amazing. So how did she come to write it? Because that in itself is a remarkable story. Yes, and may well be made up. So this is part of the fun of reading the Pillow Book is that Say Shonaghan is very, she's very playful. You can never entirely trust what she's saying, I think. So the name Pillow Book, it comes from the story of how she comes to write it. So the story she gives is that a minister comes to the Empress who is Say Shonaghan's mistress, presents the Empress with a great sheaf of paper, and the Empress who is, say, Shonaghan's mistress, presents the Empress with a great sheaf of paper and the Empress makes a gift of it to, say, Shonaghan and she uses this paper to
把这叠纸当成礼物送给了清少纳言，而清少纳言用这些纸来开始记录观察、想法、经历，无论什么都可以，而且她似乎把这叠纸放在她的枕头下面或旁边。后来她离开了宫廷，并继续写作。然后有一天，哎呀天哪，她被一位前来向她致敬的州长打扰了。于是她把枕头抽出来让州长坐，结果那一叠纸就在下面，清少纳言感到非常尴尬。我手忙脚乱地试图把它们抢回来，但他把它们带走了，并且拿了很长时间才还给她。这似乎就是这本书第一次为人所知的时刻，她说：我很尴尬，竟然传出去了，太尴尬了。人们竟然读了我写的这部杰作，太可怕了。
start recording observations, thoughts, experiences, whatever, and she seems to have kept the sheaf of papers either under or next to her pillow. And she then leaves the court and continues to write it. And then one day, oh me, oh my, she is disturbed by a governor who comes to pay his respects to her. And so she pulls out the pillow for the governor to sit on and there are the sheaf of papers and say Shonagon is so mortified. I scrambled to try and retrieve them, but he carried them off with him and kept them for a very long time before returning them. That seems to have been the moment when this book first become known and she says, I'm mortified, mortified that it's got out. It's terrible that people have read this masterpiece that I've written.
很显然，她是在利用人们对她的期望来开玩笑，因为作为一个女性，她本该感到尴尬。这可以说是贯穿她全书幽默的那种微妙与矛盾的典型代表。因此，对于那些还没有读过这本书的人（我猜听节目的绝大多数人都没有读过），让我们来解释一下它到底是什么。因为正如你所说，一想到当她写下这些时，无准备者埃塞雷德（Ethelred the Unready）正在向奥拉夫·特里格维森（Olaf Tryggvason）支付丹麦金，这简直太疯狂了。
And clearly she's making play with the expectation that she, as a woman, was supposed to be mortified. And this is kind of typical of the, I guess, the kind of the subtlety and the ambivalence that characterises her humour throughout the book. So let's, for people who've not read it, which I'm guessing is most people listen to the show, let's explain exactly what it is. Because as you said, it's bonkers to think that while she is writing this, Etherered the Unready is paying Dane Gale to Olaf Trigversen. That is mad.
为了让大家有个概念，它有点像日记条目、期刊条目、关于自然和季节的随想、关于宫廷的趣闻轶事、爱情与浪漫故事的合集，所有这些都杂糅在一起，以至于你永远不知道每个条目的下一篇会是什么。我的意思，《源氏物语》你还能认出它是一部小说，但《枕草子》真的不同于以往写过的任何作品。我想如果你非要把它和什么东西作比较的话，或许可以和一个博客相比，甚至可以说是某种……你知道的，你能想象到的最好的那种播客，它不断地发散到各种各样的话题中，但每一个话题都完全令人着迷。
And to give people a sense, it's a kind of a compilation of diary entries, journal entries, random thoughts about nature and the seasons, anecdotes about the Imperial Court, stories of love and romance, all jumbled together so you never know what's going to be next in each entry. I mean, The Tale of Genji, you can recognise it as a novel, but the Pillow Book is unlike really anything that's been written since. And I guess if you had to compare it to anything, perhaps to a blog, perhaps even to a kind of, you know, the best kind of podcast you could possibly imagine, where it's constantly kind of going off on various tangents, but every tangent is completely fascinating. So the genius of it
对于清少纳言来说，它的天才之处在于，本质上它是一个框架，在这个框架里她可以写任何她感兴趣的东西。因此你会得到开头那种抒情式的描写，通常这些都是让她感到快乐的事物的描写。她所传达的幸福感，我认为今天的人们依然能够感同身受。所以，冬天在一个极冷的夜晚是多么愉快，当你躺在那里倾听，蜷缩在厚厚的被窝深处，寺庙的钟声以如此深沉而遥远的迴响傳来，听起来就像是从某处深深埋藏的地方发出的。所以你同时身处 11 世纪的日本，感受着钟声的敲响。但同时，我的意思是，那是一种普遍的体验，不是吗？我的意思是，在一个寒冷的夜晚睡在温暖的被窝里的快乐。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。
for Seishonogun is that essentially it's a framework in which she can write about anything that interests her. So you get lyrical descriptions of the kind with which you open, and often these are descriptions of things that make her happy. And the sense of happiness that she conveys is something that I think people could still identify with today. So, how delightful it is in winter on a fiercely cold night when you're lying there listening, snuggled far down under the bedclothes, and the sound of a temple bell comes to you with such a deep and distant reverberation that it seems to be emerging from somewhere buried. So you're simultaneously there in 11th century Japan, the sense of a bell ringing. But also, I mean, that is a universal experience, isn't it? I mean, the joy of being warm in bed in a cold night. I mean, it's incredible.
完全正确。另一件事，她非常喜欢列清单。事实上，当我在日本时，我意识到这在日本是一个延续至今的传统。所以你去一个城堡，然后说：这是日本第四好的城堡，诸如此类。他们非常喜欢这样。这显然是从清少纳言开始的。所以她会列出顶级山脉、顶级池塘、顶级马匹，所有诸如此类的东西。在她的顶级鸟类清单中，她不太喜欢苍鹭。她说苍鹭看起来太可怕了。可怕。是的。非常喜欢鸳鸯，她说鸳鸯在寒冷的夜晚相互交替位置以掸去彼此翅膀上的冰霜的那种方式非常感人。
Exactly. The other thing, she loves a list. And actually, when I was in Japan, I realized that this is a continuing thing in Japan. So you go to a castle and say, this is the fourth best castle in Japan or that kind of thing. They love it. And it clearly begins with say Shonagun. So she will list top mountains, top ponds, top horses, all that kind of thing. Her list of top birds, she's not keen on the heron. She says the heron looks horrible. Horrible. Yeah. Very keen on the Mandarin duck, which she says is very touching in the way the pair will change places on cold nights to brush the frost from each other's wings.
我想日本人总体上非常喜欢鸳鸯，因为它似乎一直是夫妻忠诚的象征。因此，在紫式部的小说中，源氏在月光下与他的挚爱紫式部漫步时，他听到了一只鸳鸯的叫声。这让他产生了一种强烈的普鲁斯特式的记忆冲击，想起了他与紫式部度过的所有时光，这勾起了他对已经逝去的美好时光的深情回忆。但最好的部分是那些既疯狂又符合人们在社交媒体或博客上所写的那类清单。
And I think the Japanese generally are very keen on the Mandarin duck because it seems to have been an emblem of marital fidelity. So Genji in Murasaki's novel, he's walking out under the moonlight with Murasaki, his great love, and he hears a Mandarin duck. He has this great Proustian rush of memory thinking of all the times that he's spent with Murasaki and it brings back fond memories of times now gone by. But the best things are the lists that are simultaneously bonkers, but also the kind of things that people write on social media or on blogs.
有点像列表文。是的，列表文。所以你写下了你最喜欢的一些。我这里有几个，她有一列人们鄙视的事物，其中之一是：那些以异常性格温和而闻名的人。是的，这几乎有点像王尔德式的幽默，对吧？是的。或者罕见的事物。
Kind of listicles. Yeah, listicles. So you've got some of your favourites written down. So a couple of mine are, she's got a list of things people despise, one of which is, people who have a reputation for being exceptionally good natured. Yeah, it's kind of almost like Oscar Wilde, isn't it? Yeah. Or rare things.
一个受到妻子父亲赞扬的女婿。同样地，一个受到婆婆喜爱的妻子。然后，在“罕见的事物”这一条目下，她写的下一项是一把真正能正确拔出毛发的银质镊子。一件令人尴尬的事。这对于任何去过学校门口的人来说都会非常熟悉。某人坚持向你讲述某个讨厌的小孩，她自己对这个小家伙迷恋得无法自拔，一边模仿它的声音，一边滔滔不绝地谈论它说的那些可爱迷人的话。
A son-in-law who is praised by his wife's father. Likewise, a wife who is loved by her mother-in-law. And then the next entry under rare things she's written is a pair of silver tweezers that can actually pull out hairs properly. An embarrassing thing. And this will be so familiar, I think, to anyone who has ever been at the school gates. Someone insists on telling you about some horrid little child carried away with her own infatuation with the creature imitating its voice as she gushes about the cute and winning things it says.
而清少纳言总体上似乎并不是很喜欢小孩子。所以她还指责三岁的孩子自以为是、傲慢自大，这是显而易见的。我的意思是，她并没有说错。所以你拥有所有这些不可思议的清单。令人作呕的事物。你看到了吗？令人作呕的事物。猫耳朵的里面。我的意思是，这是真的。而且我也喜欢这个：当一个男人对一个他并不是真的很喜欢的妻子长期生病时，他心里一定会有那种感觉。是的，这太精彩了。此外，还有一些关于宫廷生活的精彩轶事。所以
And Sage Enegan generally doesn't seem to be very fond of children. So she also accuses three year olds of being smug and cocky, which is obvious. I mean, she's not wrong. And so you've got all these incredible lists. Repulsive things. You saw that? Repulsive things. The inside of a cat's ear. I mean, that's true. But also, I love this one. The way a man must feel when his wife, who he's not really very fond of, is ill for a long time. Yeah, it's wonderful. And also there are kind of brilliant anecdotes about court life. So
有一个非常精彩的故事，比如，有一场大雪，园丁们把所有的雪都扫到一起，堆成了一座巨大的雪山。皇后和她所有的女官（包括清少纳言）打了个赌，赌这座雪山在融化之前能维持多久。清少纳言说：哦，它能维持好几周，好几周又好几周。每个人都说：不，那太疯狂了。你绝对做不到。她和皇后打了赌，清少纳言描述说（你知道的），她每天都去检查雪山的状况，在几周的过程中，雪山渐渐变得越来越脏，直到完全变黑，但它依然非常结实地立在那里。她有一个园丁来向她汇报雪山的状态，还有
there's an amazing story, for instance, about how there's a great snowfall and the gardeners sweep up all the snow and they make a huge snow mountain. And the Empress and all her ladies in waiting, including Sae Shonaghan have a kind of sweepstake on how long this snow mountain will last before it melts. And Sae Shonaghan says, oh, it'll last for weeks, weeks and weeks. And everyone says, no, that's, that's mad. You'll never do that. And she has a bet with the Empress and Sae Shonenigen described, you know, every day she goes to inspect the state of the snow mountain and gradually over the course of the weeks, it gets dirtier and dirtier and dirtier until it's completely black, but it's still very solid there. And she has a gardener who comes to report to, you know, on the state of the mountain and
一切情况，到了傍晚它依然还在。她显然要赢下这场赌局了。而在早晨，园丁说：它没了，已经消失了。结果证明，皇后让人来把它扫走了，作弊了。清少纳言跑去向天皇抱怨这件事。天皇笑了笑，评论道：嗯，我想她只是不想看你赢罢了。而且一想到这是 11 世纪的宫廷。我的意思是，那种趣闻轶事（我们在上一集里也说过），为了从忏悔者爱德华或其他什么人的宫廷里得到这样一个故事，你愿意付出什么代价？
everything and the evening before it's still there. She's clearly going to win the bet. And in the morning, the gardener says, it's gone, it's been vanished. And it turns out that the Empress has had people come in and sweep it away and cheat. And say Schoenigen goes and complains to the emperor about this. And he smiles and remarks, well, I suppose she just didn't want to see you win. And to think that this is an 11th century court. I mean, that kind of anecdote, you know, we said this in the last episode. What wouldn't you give for a story like that from the court of Edward the Confessor or something?
一切都好，甚至连前一天晚上的也还在。她显然要赢得打赌了。到了早晨，园丁却说，东西不见了，已经消失了。原来是皇后派人来打扫干净并作弊了。清少纳言去向皇帝抱怨这件事。皇帝微笑着说，嗯，我想她大概只是不想看到你赢吧。想想看，这可是11世纪的宫廷。我的意思是，这种趣闻，正如我们在上一集里所说的那样，为了能从忏悔者爱德华或其他什么人的宫廷里听到这样一个故事，你愿意付出什么代价？
But in a way you couldn't have had a story like that because a literary document like that to come from the court of Edward the Confessor or any kind of early medieval European court would just seem unthinkable, wouldn't it? It would seem impossible. But as we said last time, it comes from a very specific set of circumstances. And I guess the misleading thing when we read this is we think of Shea Shonagon as our contemporary, because we can recognize so much of what she's saying about the relations between parents and children and about annoying
但在某种程度上，你不可能有这样的故事，因为来自埃德ワード·忏悔者宫廷或任何早期中世纪欧洲宫廷的文学文献会显得不可思议，不是吗？这似乎是不可能的。但正如我们上次所说，它源于一组非常特定的环境。我想，当我们阅读这本书时，容易产生误解的地方在于，我们会把清少纳言当作我们的同时代人，因为我们能从她对父母与孩子关系以及烦人事物的描述中，产生极大的共鸣。
things that people do and tweezers that don't work properly and all of these kinds of things. But she is still very alien. I mean, she's from a world that could not seem more alien. Yeah. And she is clearly a product of the court culture that she adorns. And I think it's evident that she is giving court culture the best spin that she possibly can. And I think that's probably because she does love it, because she is such court culture the best spin that she possibly can. And I think that's
人们所做的各种事情、不好用的镊子以及所有这类事情。但她依然非常陌生。我的意思是，她来自一个再陌生不过的世界。是的。而且她显然是她所点缀的宫廷文化的产物。我认为显而易见的是，她正在尽她所能地为宫廷文化做最好的粉饰。我想这可能是因为她确实热爱它，因为她是宫廷文化的狂热支持者，她尽其所能地为宫廷文化进行美化。我想这
probably because she does love it, because she is such a brilliant figure at court. I mean, that's, you know, she, that's wonderful. And so there's this word, apparently again, marshalling my fluent Japanese, kashi, which can be translated as delightful, amusing, charming, fun, I suppose, exquisite, whatever. And this is essentially the word she uses to describe so many things that happen at court. But when you look at Murasaki's diary, which is a kind of parallel to the pillow book, she's much more introverted, much more morose, I think. And she gives a darker portrait of life at court. So, Sochonigan adores gossip. I mean, she praises it. What
可能是因为她真的很爱它，因为她是宫廷里一个如此才华横溢的人物。我的意思是，那，你知道，她，那太棒了。所以有一个词，显然又是我的流利日语大显身手的时候了，kashi，它可以被翻译为令人愉快的、好玩的、迷人的、有趣的，我想，精致的，诸如此类。这基本上就是她用来形容宫廷中发生的许多事情的词。但当你看看紫式部的日记时，那有点像《枕草子》的姊妹篇，她要内向得多，也阴郁得多，我认为。她对宫廷生活给出了一个更黑暗的描绘。所以，清少纳言非常喜欢八卦。我的意思是，她对八卦赞不绝口。有什么
could possibly be more fun than talking about other people and criticizing them, she writes. Yeah, she's not wrong. Whereas Murasaki beats herself up about being a gossip. And unlike her rival, she confesses to loneliness, to isolation. There's no doubt. Which of those women would fit in well as a guest on the rest of history? Well, yeah, you're probably right. But I think when you combine, say, the writings of these two extraordinary authors, what you get is a sense that this court is, if you want to say, civilised to the nth degree. I mean, it's kind of the epitome of civilization. And when
比谈论别人和批评别人更有趣的事情呢，她写道。是的，她没有说错。而紫式部则为自己是个八卦而感到内疚。与她的竞争对手不同，她坦承自己的孤独和孤立。毫无疑问。这两个女人中哪一个会很适合作为《历史的其余部分》的嘉宾呢？好吧，是的，你可能是对的。但我想，当你把这两位非凡作家的著作结合起来时，你会感受到这个宫廷，如果要说的话，是高度文明的。我的意思是，它是文明的化身。当
the Japanese, as they have done ever since the 11th century, celebrate the Heian court as the kind of the great classical age of elegance, of sophistication, of style, I mean, they're not wrong. And Dominic, we, after this episode, we're going to be embarking on a six-part series on the life of Peter the Great. And there is a lot of kind of malarkey with drunk bears and bellows being shoved up bottoms and things. Correct. Peter the Great's court is not elegant.
日本人像自11世纪以来一直做的那样，将平安宫廷歌颂为优雅、精致、风格的伟大古典时代时，我的意思是，他们并没有错。多米尼克，在这一集之后，我们将开始一个关于彼得大帝生平的六集系列节目。里面有很多乱七八糟的事情，比如喝醉的熊、被塞进屁股的风箱之类的东西。没错。彼得大帝的宫廷一点也不优雅。
This court absolutely is. That really would be a culture clash if these women are pitched up at the court of Peter the Great. I suspect Sage Onaghan would have done quite well, but Murasaki probably would have hated it. So Tom, a very good example of that degree of sophistication and kind of elegance is poetry. And poetry matters enormously to Shae Shonigan, doesn't it? As it does to Genji in The Tale of Genji.
这个宫廷绝对是优雅的。如果这些女性来到彼得大帝的宫廷，那真的会是一场文化冲突。我怀疑清少纳言会表现得相当不错，但紫式部大概会讨厌那里。所以，汤姆，这种程度的精致和优雅的一个很好的例子就是诗歌。诗歌对清少纳言来说极其重要，不是吗？正如它对《源氏物语》中的源氏一样重要。
Yeah, so Genji is a brilliant poet. And it has a significance that we might in the 21st century in Britain, or indeed in any Western country, really struggle to understand because mastery of poetry is enormously important as a badge of status and as a badge of elegance of, I mean, you know, to be a desirable, attractive person, an impressive person, you should be able to quote poems and come up with poems on the spot. But also of your ability. I mean, it's kind of, you know, people today have to have a mastery of IT or whatever. In the Heian court, you have to have a mastery of poetry. Right.
是的，所以源氏是一位出色的诗人。它具有一种我们在21世纪的英国、甚至任何西方国家可能都难以理解的重要意义，因为精通诗歌作为身份和优雅的象征极其重要，我的意思是，你知道的，要想成为一个令人向往的、有吸引力的人，一个令人印象深刻的人，你应该能够即兴引用诗句并创作诗歌。但这同时也关乎你的能力。我的意思是，这有点像，你知道的，今天的人们必须精通IT或其他什么。在平安宫廷，你必须精通诗歌。没错。
And to quote Ivan Morris, the composition change and quotation of poems was central to the daily life of the Heian aristocracy and it is doubtful whether any other society in the world has ever attached such important to the poetic versatility of its members. And so this is a crucial part of say, Shonigan's fame at the court is she's not just a brilliant poet, but she's also very, very knowledgeable about poetry. And so if someone sends in a quote, she can rework it, she can refashion it in a kind of exquisitely witty way. And so if someone sends in a quote, she can rework it, she can refashion it in a kind of exquisitely witty way. And it's no wonder that Forosaki hates her because she's just brilliant at it. It imposes incredible strain because if you mess it up, you know, if you misquote something, if your poem is felt not quite to hit the mark, then that's
借用伊万·莫里斯的话来说，“诗歌的创作、改写和引用是平安贵族日常生活核心，世界上是否还有其他社会曾对其成员的诗歌才华赋予如此重要的意义，实在令人怀疑。”因此，这是清少纳言在宫廷中声名鹊起的一个关键部分，她不仅是一位才华横溢的诗人，而且对诗歌有着非常非常渊博的知识。因此，如果有人送来一句名言，她可以将其重新加工，以一种极其机智的方式重新塑造它。因此，如果有人送来一句名言，她可以将其重新加工，以一种极其机智的方式重新塑造它。难怪紫式部讨厌她，因为她在这一方面实在是太出色了。这带来了令人难以置信的压力，因为如果你把事情搞砸了，你知道，如果你引用错误，如果你的诗被认为没有达到预期效果，那么这将
terribly damaging to your reputation and even say Schoenegger admits this. So somebody sends a poem, you become very anxious when you have to make a quick response to someone's poem and you can't come up with anything. If it's a lover, there's no particular need to hurry to send a reply, but there are times when circumstances make it necessary. And if it's some exchange with a lady, nothing special, and you feel you can just dash something off, that's precisely when you're inclined to make an unfortunate blunder. So it gives a really vivid sense of, you know, the tension of not losing status and rank by sending out a kind of dud few lines. Well, there's an amazing scene very early in the book where the empress says to, she folds up a
对你的名誉造成可怕的损害，甚至连清少纳言也承认这一点。所以当有人发来一首诗，你必须对别人的诗做出快速回应却又想不出任何东西时，你会变得非常焦虑。如果对方是恋人，倒不特别需要急着回信，但有时环境使得不得不回。如果只是与某位夫人的交流，没什么特别的，你觉得自己可以随便应付一下，恰恰在那种时候你最容易犯下不幸的错误。因此，这非常生动地展现了那种紧张感：通过发送几行糟糕的诗句来避免失去地位和等级。好吧，书中很早有一个惊人的场景，皇后对，她折叠了一张
piece of paper and she says to all her kind of ladies and waiting in her courtiers, now I want each of you to write here the first ancient poem that springs to mind. And Shaye Shonigan is in a complete and utter panic and she says to a male official, what on earth can I write? And he pushes her the paper back and says, quick, write something down yourself for Her Majesty. It's not a man's place to give advice here. And she does write something down. And she says, I felt a sudden sweat break out all over me. But then she praises herself because she's very full of herself since she, she says, I do think though that the poem of mine isn't the sort of thing that a young person could have come up with.
纸，然后对她所有的宫女和朝臣说：“现在我要你们每个人在这里写下脑海中最先浮现的古诗。”清少纳言陷入了彻底的恐慌中，她对一个男官员说：“我到底能写什么？”他把纸推回给她说：“快，为你自己给陛下的诗写点东西。这里可不是男人给建议的地方。”她确实写下了一些东西。她说：“我感到全身突然直冒冷汗。”但随后她称赞了自己，因为她非常自我感觉良好，她，她写道：“不过，我的诗确实不是一个年轻人能想得出来的。”
She's very proud of herself. You get this sort of sense of this really, this would taint her for you. People would laugh at her for years. You know, when you're at the top, every slip will be fatal because there are lots of people who want to replace her as the, you well not the queen, I mean, but the queen bee perhaps among the ladies in waiting. And a further cause of anxiety is it's not enough just to compose it, but you have to write it as implied in the passage that you quoted.
她为自己感到非常自豪。你会有一种感觉，这真的会玷污她的名声。人们会嘲笑她好几年。你知道，当你处于巅峰时，任何失误都可能是致命的，因为有很多人想取代她成为——好吧，虽然不是女王，但也许是宫女中的“女王蜂”。另一个让人焦虑的原因是，仅仅创作出来是不够的，你还得像你引用的段落中所暗示的那样把它写下来。
And writing calligraphy is also a crucial part of establishing yourself as civilized. So Genji, for instance, in Murasaki's novel takes for granted that calligraphy is the surest window into a person's soul that you can possibly find and that beautiful writing equates to a kind of moral beauty. And there's a whole chapter in the tale of Genji where he and his mates just sit around and talk about calligraphy. For them it is one of the most important things in the world. And they agree everything is going to the dogs except for calligraphy, which has hugely improved. And say Shonigan likewise, I mean it's often features in the
书写书法也是确立自己为文明人的关键部分。例如，在紫式部的小说中，源氏理所当然地认为书法是通往一个人灵魂最确凿的窗口，美丽的书写等同于某种道德之美。在《源氏物语》中有一整章，他和他的同伴们就坐在那里谈论书法。对他们来说，这是世界上最重要的事情之一。他们一致认为一切都在退步，唯独书法大有长进。清少纳言同样如此，我的意思是，这经常出现在她喜爱的
list of things that she loves. So things that make you feel cheerful, something written in very delicate strokes with just the tip of an almost impossibly thick brush on a lovely clean white sheet of Michinoku paper. I mean, we're a long way from the Anglo-Saxon court there, I think. And the other thing that makes this, if people are not interested in poetry, I think, well, who cares about a load of poems? To be good at poetry and to be able to write this beautiful kind of calligraphy, this is really important, not just for your social standing, but basically if you want to have
事物清单中。所以，那些让你感到心情愉快的事物，是在一张干净洁白的道陆纸上，用几乎粗得不可思议的笔尖，以极其细腻的笔触写下的东西。我想，我们与盎格鲁-撒克逊宫廷相比，已经相去甚远了。另一件让这一点变得重要的事情是，如果人们对诗歌不感兴趣，我想，谁会在乎一堆诗呢？擅长写诗并且能够写出这种美丽的书法，这真的非常重要，不仅为了你的社会地位，基本上如果你想拥有
any sexual or romantic success, you have to be good at this. I mean, you know, it makes thinking up a good chat up line look, you know, trivial by comparison. I mean, it's kind of like opening proceedings on social media when you never actually met the person. It's a little bit like that because the poem is seen as your window onto the world. An erotic adventure at the court is a crucial part of kind of the broader social dynamics and it's celebrated by say Shonaghan, who again, seems to have been tremendously good at it. I mean, she certainly gives that impression. But Murasaki as well, even though in her personal relations
任何性和浪漫上的成功，你都必须擅长这些。我的意思是，你知道的，这让想出一句好的搭讪台词相形见绌，显得微不足道。我的意思是，这有点像在从未见过面的情况下在社交媒体上开启对话。有点像那样，因为这首诗被视为你了解世界的窗口。宫廷中的情色冒险是更广泛社会动力学的一个关键部分，并受到清少纳言的颂扬，她似乎在这方面也做得非常出色。我的意思是，她确实给人留下了这种印象。但紫式部也是如此，尽管在个人交往中
she seems to have been viewed actually as a bit of a prude. And it reflects the way in which women are given a degree of kind of license that I think in the Muslim or Christian world would have prompted a lot of anxiety on the part of male moralists. There are absolutely rules, I mean, very strict rules. But the whole point is that you master the rules and then all kinds of opportunities open up and that's precisely the thrill and the fun of it. So for women especially, the reason that you want to be very good at poetry is that you are not supposed to show yourself to men who are courting you. You stay behind a screen. And so how then are you meant to establish relations with a man if the man can't actually see you, if you have to stay cloistered away behind a screen. And this is where the poetry comes
她似乎实际上被视为有点保守。这反映了女性获得了一定程度的许可，我认为这在穆斯林或基督教世界会引起男性道德家的大量焦虑。规则当然是存在的，我的意思是，非常严格的规则。但关键在于，你掌握了规则，然后各种机会就会敞开，这正是其中的刺激和乐趣所在。因此，特别是对女性来说，你想要非常擅长写诗的原因是，你是不应该让追求你的男人看到自己的。你呆在屏风后面。那么，如果男人实际上看不到你，如果你必须隐居在屏风后面，你又该如何与一个男人建立关系呢？这就是诗歌派上用场的地方
in. You kind of exchange verses. And if this goes well, and if the man thinks, yeah, that's witty, that's well expressed or whatever, then other markers of taste can be unleashed. And this is what Genji is so good at. He is in Murasaki's novel, the absolute master of these kind of arts of courtship. So the poetry comes first, then you might have incense mixing. So remember Genji is perfumed. Say Shonagun is very good on how wonderful, beautiful scents are and how awful hideous swans are is clearly very, very important in the court. Calligraphy, of course, there's a passage in the tale of Genji where the war
。你们互相交换诗句。如果进展顺利，如果男人觉得，嗯，这很机智，表达得很妙之类的，那么其他品味的标志就可以被释放出来。这就是源氏如此擅长的东西。在紫式部的小说中，他是这类求爱艺术的绝对大师。所以诗歌排在第一位，然后你可能会有香料的混合。所以记住，源氏身上带有香气。清少纳言对于美妙的香气有多棒以及恶臭的恶臭有多糟糕有着非常好的见解，这在宫廷中显然非常非常重要。书法，当然，在《源氏物语》中有一个片段，兵部
minister literally sobs over Genji's calligraphy and you can't kind of imagine, I don't know, Pete Hegseth weeping over JD Vance's handwriting. That's such a great image. It's not going to happen. And then of course, there's the exquisiteness of dress and so on. So the woman would wear perhaps very, very long sleeves and she would very decorously allow perhaps just a glimpse from behind the
卿对着源氏的书法失声痛哭，你简直无法想象，我不知道，皮特·海格塞斯会为JD·万斯的笔迹哭泣。这真是一个极好的意象。这绝不可能发生。然后当然还有服饰的精致等等。因此，女性可能会穿着非常非常长的衣袖，她会非常得体地只允许从屏风背后隐约露出一点
screen. So it's that kind of thing, you know, a glimpse of ankle. And in due course, a woman who decides that she is happy to allow a man to pay court to her, this would initiate a series of secret nighttime visits. And when I say secret, it's not really secret because there is effectively no privacy in these. Right, because people would see you coming and going, wouldn't they? Yeah. So the screens operate as walls within rooms, but I mean, they're not permanent walls, so ultimately there isn't really any privacy. And it means that in poetry, in prose, in both the Tale of Genji and the Pillow Book, the coming of dawn is a repeated theme because it's absolutely touched with
。所以就是那种事情，你知道的，隐约露出脚踝。在适当的时候，一个决定允许一个男人向她求爱的女性，这将引发一系列秘密的夜间拜访。当我说秘密时，这其实并不是秘密，因为在这些事情中实际上根本没有隐私。没错，因为人们会看到你进进出出，不是吗？是的。所以屏风在房间里起到了墙壁的作用，但我的意思是，它们不是永久的墙壁，所以最终其实并没有任何隐私。这意味着在诗歌、散文、以及《源氏物语》和《枕草子》中，黎明的到来是一个重复出现的主题，因为它绝对带有一种
a sense of the erotic and say Schoenaguen is predictably brilliant on it. So she writes, summer provides the most delightful setting for a secret assignation. The nights are so very short that dawn breaks before you've slept. Everything has been left open all night and there's a lovely cool feel to the expansive view. The lovers still have a little more they must say to each other. As they sit there murmuring endearments, they're startled into a sudden panicky sensation of exposure by the loud core of a passing crow. A delightful moment. So there's a lovely section at the beginning of the pillow book when she's describing a woman and her lover. The lover has just left and another bloke is passing because he's leaving an
情色感，而清少纳言对此的表现可以说是意料之中的精彩。因此她写道：“夏天为秘密幽会提供了最令人愉快的背景。夜晚是如此短暂，以至于还没睡着天就亮了。整晚一切都是敞开的，开阔的视野带有一种可爱而凉爽的感觉。恋人们还有一些话必须对彼此说。正当他们坐在那里呢喃着爱意时，一只路过的乌鸦的粗嘎叫声让他们突然惊醒，产生了一种惊慌失措的暴露感。这是一个美妙的时刻。”因此，《枕草子》开头有一段非常精彩的部分，她描写了一位女性和她的情夫。情夫刚走，另一个家伙路过，因为他要离开他自己的
assignation of his own and he sees through the sort of gap in the screen. That she's still lying there on the bed and she kind of knows he can see her. And it's a sort of passage again, you know, your mind explodes trying to think about, you know, somebody at the court of Ethelred the Unready writing this with such delicacy and such a sort of sense of tenderness and melancholy and erotic feeling and whatnot that's just unimaginable in medieval literature otherwise. It obviously reflects different social, cultural, sexual expectations. And Christian Europe is a monogamous culture.
幽会，他透过屏风的某种缝隙看到她仍然躺在床上，她有点知道他能看见她。这又是一个这样的片段，你知道，你的大脑在思考时会彻底炸裂，想象一下，埃塞尔雷德无准备之王宫廷中的某个人以如此细腻、如此温柔、感伤和情色感的情调写下这些，这在其他中世纪文学中是简直不可想象的。这显然反映了不同的社会、文化和性观念。基督教欧洲是一个一夫一妻制的文化。
That's not the case in Japan. So these courtships might lead to marriage or it might lead to a kind of polygamous relationship, a kind of secondary degree of marriage of the kind that Genji is so fond of, or it might just be a fling. I mean, it's perfectly fine to just kind of have an affair. And obviously, women are absolutely not passive actors in this. You know. They have to project their erotic appeal as well, which is very difficult when you start behind a screen. So there are certain things that are obviously very important to you that we touched on one of them already, and that is smell. So it's an abiding theme in The Tale of Genji. Women
日本并非如此。因此，这些求爱可能会通向婚姻，或者可能会通向一种一夫多妻制的关系，一种源氏非常喜欢的次要程度的婚姻，或者它可能只是一次艳遇。我的意思是，有一段风流韵事是完全没问题的。很显然，女性绝对不是这其中的被动参与者。你知道的。她们也必须展现出自己的性吸引力，这在躲在屏风后面时是非常困难的。因此，有些事情对你来说显然非常重要，我们刚才已经谈到了其中之一，那就是气味。所以这是《源氏物语》中一个常青的主题。女性
are worried about their perspiration, that they might be giving off body odor. Where Saishanigan typically riffs on this. I mean, she's kind of original. So she says, you know, it's charming, a lightly padded kimono that gives off a faint whiff of perspiration. She, she thinks that's actually quite erotic for a man. And also she gives advice on insure, because obviously it's a problem if a man is coming and the woman is behind a screen. How is he to know that the woman is there? I mean, she might've gone to bed or something.
担心自己的汗水，担心自己可能会散发出体臭。而清少纳言通常会对这一点进行即兴发挥。我的意思是，她挺有创意的。所以她说，你知道的，这很迷人，一件略微加厚并散发出淡淡汗水味的轻便和服。她，她实际上认为这对于男人来说相当具有情色感。此外，她还就确保提供了建议，因为很显然，如果一个男人来访而女性在屏风后面，这会是个问题。他怎么知道女性在那里呢？我的意思是，她可能已经上床睡觉了什么的。
Yeah. So Sage Onaghan advice shifts slightly to let the rustle of clothes alert him. So all these kind of rules that I suppose, you know, are freighted with the erotic. So they're all covered up, aren't they? They're wearing, in fact, in the, in the pillar book in the Penguin Classics edition, there are pictures because clothes are so important. There are diagrams of how they're wearing these enormous, enormous robes and gowns and mantles and jackets and all kinds. And I mean, that's in large part, as we will see in due course, because it's very cold in winter, but it means that clothing becomes away again, like poetry in
是的。所以清少纳言的建议稍微转变了一下，让衣服的沙沙声提醒他。所以所有这些我猜带有情色意味的规则。所以她们都被包裹得严严实实，不是吗？她们穿着，事实上，在企鹅经典版的《枕草子》中，有图片因为衣服非常重要。有图表展示了她们是如何穿着这些庞大无比的长袍、礼服、斗篷、夹克和各种服饰的。我的意思是，这在很大程度上，正如我们随后将看到的，是因为冬天的天气非常寒冷，但这意味着服装再次成为像诗歌一样的方式
which they can project their personality. And so it's not surprising that say Shonigan and Murasaki are obsessed by clothes because the fabric, the cut, the style, the coloring, the pairing of colors, these are ways in which you can project your personality, I suppose. Yeah. Well, Chris Harding in his history of Japan that we were talking about last time These are ways in which you can project your personality, I suppose. Yeah, well, Chris Harding in his history of Japan that we were talking about last time, makes the point that our concept of fashion does not map onto Japan in this period, because for them, this is everything. You know, the way you construct your outfit, the choice of colors, the way they match, it's much more than an optional extra, than a kind of add-on, that a hobby. It's the key to your personality and the way you're perceived in
在诗歌中，她们可以展现自己的个性。因此，清少纳言和紫式部对衣服着迷也就不足为奇了，因为面料、剪裁、风格、色彩、色彩的搭配，这些都是你可以借此展现个人魅力的途径，我想。是的。嗯，克里斯·哈丁在我们上次谈到的日本历史中指出，我们对时尚的概念并不适用于这一时期的日本，因为对他们来说，这就是全部。你知道的，你构建服装的方式、颜色的选择、它们的搭配方式，远不止是一个可选的附加项，不仅仅是一种爱好。它是你个性的关键，也是你在他人眼中形象的关键。
the world. And I think also the Japanese understanding of what makes a woman physically attractive is very different. So obviously if the courtship goes well, the key moment comes where a woman has to reveal herself. The man hasn't seen her until this point. And there are very distinctive standards of beauty. So teeth have to be black. And this is a kind of recurrent theme throughout the tale of Genji, women blackening their teeth, right? Eyebrows are plucked and then painted back on. And you have to have a degree of plumpness, I think. If you're thin, this is viewed as very, very erotically off putting. And there's a sense, I think,
世界。而且我认为日本人对女性身体吸引力的理解也非常不同。所以很显然，如果求婚顺利，关键时刻就会到来，女人必须向男人展现自己。在此之前，男人还没有见过她。当时有非常独特的审美标准。牙齿必须是黑的。这也是《源氏物语》中一个反复出现的主题，女性会把牙齿染黑，对吧？眉毛要拔掉，然后再画上去。而且我认为，你还得有一定的丰满度。如果你很瘦，这会被认为是非常非常让人提不起情欲的。而且我觉得有一种感觉，
almost in which the naked body is seen as unattractive. So Murasaki writes, the naked body is unforgettably repulsive. It really does not have the slightest charm. So this is not a society in which nakedness is seen as something appealing in any way. And the real obsession is with hair. And the longer obsession is with hair and the longer it is, the smoother, the glossier, the better. And again and again in The Tale of Genji, I mean, Genji only has to see a glimpse of hair and he's off. He's unleashed. And in fact, what he will do the moment he gets a glimpse of hair, that's when he will start writing his poems. He'll start pestering the woman with his poetry. And it's hard to think of another
几乎可以说，裸体被认为是没有吸引力的。所以紫式部写道，裸体是令人难忘的厌恶。它真的没有一丝魅力。所以这不是一个以任何方式认为裸露具有吸引力的社会。真正的痴迷是头发。而对头发的执念更深，头发越长，越顺滑，越有光泽，就越好。在《源氏物语》中一次又一次，我是说，源氏只要看一眼头发，他就按捺不住了。他解放了天性。事实上，他一看到头发，就会立刻开始写诗。他会用他的诗歌去纠缠那个女性。很难想象还有哪个
culture in which the literary and the erotic are so interfused. And I think that's a crucial part of explaining why the writings of women in this period are so potent in their effect and so admired by men as well as by women. There's another woman, isn't there? There's another poet called Izumi Shikibu. And she was a contemporary of these two characters, Murasaki and Seishonogun, and she was a great femme fatale, and she kind of slept around the court and everybody thought, you know, she was a folk hero in the right word. She's celebrated as the greatest poet of her period. Yeah. And the sense that she is a femme fatale is a crucial part of that.
文化能将文学和情欲如此交融。我认为这是解释为什么这一时期的女性作品具有如此强大的影响力，并受到男性和女性共同推崇的关键部分。还有另一个女性，对吧？还有一个女诗人叫和泉式部。她是紫式部和清少纳言这两个人物的同时代人，她是一个伟大的蛇蝎美人，她在宫廷里到处和不同的人睡觉，每个人都觉得，你知道的，用“民间英雄”这个词来形容她并不准确。她被誉为她那个时代最伟大的诗人。是的。而她作为一个蛇蝎美人的形象，正是其中的关键部分。
So over the course of her life, she burns her way through two husbands, numerous lovers, two of these lovers are royal brothers who succeed each other in turn and both in turn then die. So there's a slight quality of the vamp to Izumi Shikabu. And it's a measure of, you know, her kind of glamour that within only a few generations, people are writing novels about her. And it's a measure too, of the high premium that is set on literary genius, that her scandalous reputation never threatens her reputation as a great writer. In fact,
所以在她的一生中，她经历了两个丈夫、无数的情人，其中两个情人是先后继位的皇室兄弟，而这两人后来也都相继去世了。所以和泉式部身上多少有点致命女郎的特质。而从她在短短几代人之后就成为人们小说的题材这一点来看，足以证明她的某种魅力。这也同样证明了当时对文学天才的高度重视，她那声名狼藉的名声从未威胁到她作为伟大作家的声誉。事实上，
just the opposite. So, you know, we talked about how the Japanese love a list. There is a list that is drawn up in the Middle Ages of the 36 immortal poets. And I think Izumi Shikibu is number three on that list. I mean, she's very high ranking. And the other thing, right, you said that she's a great poet, she's on the list. She's on this list and she's a great poet, despite the fact that she is a woman and that is another contrast surely with the world of Christendom or the world of the Romans for example. Or the Greeks. Or the Greeks, right, where there'd be no thought that a woman could ever compete with a man in this domain.
恰恰相反。所以，你知道的，我们谈到过日本人多么喜欢列榜单。中世纪曾拟定过一份“三十六歌仙”的名单。我认为和泉式部在这份名单上排在第三位。我的意思是，她的排名非常高。还有一件事，对吧，你刚才说她是个伟大的诗人，她在榜上。她在榜上，而且她是个伟大的诗人，尽管她是个女性，这绝对与基督教世界或例如罗马人的世界形成了鲜明对比。或者希腊人。或者希腊人，对吧，在那里人们绝不会认为女性能在这一领域与男性竞争。
So this for Japan is the Classical Age, it's the equivalent of Periclean Athens or Augustan Rome and in Periclean Athens the writers are all men, in Augustine Rome the writers are all men. But in Heian Japan, so early 11th century, almost every noteworthy author of this golden age of Japanese literature is a woman. And so it's, I think, unprecedented. I can't think of another period that is rated as one of the great ages of literature where all the writers pretty much are female. It's really amazing. And so it's not surprising, I guess, therefore, that Murasaki Shikibu or say Shonagun should have kind of been in love with a culture that gave them such a voice and absolutely taken for granted that this is the only place to be. That if you're not at
所以对日本来说，这是古典时代，它相当于伯利克里的雅典或奥古斯都的罗马，而在伯利克里的雅典，作家全都是男性，在奥古斯都的罗马，作家也全都是男性。但在平安时代的日本，也就是11世纪初，这个日本文学黄金时代里几乎每一位值得关注的作家都是女性。所以，我认为这是史无前例的。我想不出还有哪一个被评为伟大文学时代之一的时期，其作家几乎全都是女性。这真的很了不起。所以我想，难怪紫式部或清少纳言会迷恋这样一种给予她们如此话语权的文化，并且理所当然地认为这是唯一值得待的地方。如果你不在
court, what are you? That everything beyond the court is kind of darkness and barbarism. There is nothing beyond Heian-kyo that is worth seeing, that is worth knowing, that is worth visiting. So in the tale of Genji, Genji gets exiled and it's not terrible. I mean it's kind of the equivalent of being packed off to Bournemouth or something. But the way he goes on about it, I mean you'd think it was the worst thing ever, like he was Odysseus or Sinbad or something, but I mean it's really not that bad. And Sayonara in her list of Japan's top mountains doesn't name Mount Fuji, the most famous of Japanese mountains, because it's too far. Who'd be interested to see it? And in the same way, there's an
宫廷，你算什么？宫廷之外的一切都带有某种黑暗和野蛮。京城之外没有任何东西值得一看，值得了解，值得造访。所以在《源氏物语》中，源氏被流放了，但这并没有那么糟糕。我的意思是，这有点像是被打包发配到伯恩茅斯之类的地方。但他对此喋喋不休的样子，我的意思是，你会觉得这是最糟糕的事情，就像他是奥德修斯或辛巴德一样，但我的意思是，真的没那么糟。清少纳言在她的日本顶级山峰名单中没有提及富士山，这座日本最著名的山脉，因为它太远了。谁会有兴趣去看它呢？同样地，其中也弥漫着一种
incredible tone of snobbery that runs through. It's in the tale of Genji, where basically no one who isn't from an aristocratic background gets a look in. But Say Shonigan makes an absolute art form of it. And so inevitably she has a list of vulgarities and top of her list of vulgarities is snow on the houses of common people. Because the sight of snow is exquisitely beautiful, it's charming, it's delightful. You see it on the house of common person, awful. And I think that she is kind of mocking herself there, but obviously she's also simultaneously it's coming from deep well springs of snobbery. And so effectively not to be part of Heian Kyo is, you know, you might as well be dead.
令人难以置信的势利语调。这在《源氏物语》中随处可见，基本上没有哪个不是来自贵族背景的人能入得了法眼。但清少纳言把这一点发挥成了一门绝对的艺术。所以不可避免地，她有一份粗俗事物清单，而她的粗俗清单之首就是平民房屋上的雪。因为雪景是极其美丽的，它迷人、动人、赏心悦目。你如果在平民的房子上看到它，那就太糟了。而且我认为她在那里面有点在自嘲，但很显然她同时也深深扎根于极度势利的源泉之中。因此，实际上，如果不属于平安京，你知道的，你还不如死了算了。
But I guess Tom, a precondition for this world is that it's peaceful. They can afford to be putting all their energy into calligraphy and being snobbish about snow on the houses of the common people and talking about how repulsive three-year-old children are precisely because Japan is at peace. Yes. But I guess, I mean, one of the themes that runs through the Pillow Book is the sense of time and aging and the passing of the seasons and everything must have an end. And I guess the writers of the Heian court, as much as anybody, are aware that time is slipping away as it were, and that this world of peace and tranquility and elegance and
但我想汤姆，这个世界的一个前提条件是它是和平的。他们能够把所有的精力投入到书法中，对平民房屋上的雪表现得势利，谈论三岁小孩是多么令人反感，正是因为日本处于和平状态。是的。不过我想，我的意思是，《枕草子》中贯穿的一个主题是对时间、衰老以及季节更替的感知，万物皆有终结。我想平安宫廷的作家们，和其他任何人一样，都意识到时间正在从指缝间溜走，而这个充满和平、宁静、优雅和
sophistication may be for the ash heap of history? Well, I think there is absolutely a sense that the very exquisite quality of life at the court can never be taken for granted and that it is always shadowed. And in the second half, perhaps we could look at some of those shadows. Very good. We'll see you after the break.
精致的世界，或许也将化作历史的灰烬？嗯，我认为确实有一种感觉，即宫廷中精致的生活品质是绝对不能理所当然的，它总是伴随着阴影。也许在下半场，我们可以看看其中的一些阴影。很好。我们休息后见。
Hi there. I'm Al Murray, co-host of WW2 pod. We have ways of making you talk the world's premier second world war history podcast from Goalhanger. And I'm James Holland. And together we tell the greatest stories from the war. Our latest series focuses on the 80th anniversary of victory in Europe and the often untold closing stages of World War II. And we've got so much to talk about in this series from the
大家好。我是阿尔·默里，是《我们有办法让你开口》的联合主持人，这是来自Goalhanger播客的全球首屈一指的第二次世界大战历史播客。我是詹姆斯·霍兰德。我们共同讲述战争中最伟大的故事。我们的最新系列聚焦于欧洲胜利80周年，以及二战中那些常常不为人知的尾声阶段。在这个系列中，我们有太多的话题要聊，从
daring allied crossings of the river Rhine to the last hours in the bombed out streets of Berlin. It is amazing how little this has been talked about before in popular media. Exactly Al, and this is more than just units moving across maps, but real human stories on an individual level, as well as great powers jostling in a new nuclear world. If this sounds good to you, we've got a short taste for you. Search We Have Ways wherever you get your podcasts. Genji pretended not to look at her and gazed into the garden, but he gave her many a sidelong glance. What was she like? How glad he would be, foolish hope, if their present intimacy
盟军Daring般强渡莱茵河，到柏林被轰炸后的街道上的最后时刻。令人惊叹的是，在此之前大众媒体对这些内容的讨论是如此之少。确实是这样，阿尔，这不仅仅是地图上的部队调动，更是个人层面的真实人性故事，以及大国在一个全新的核世界中的博览角逐。如果你觉得这听起来不错，我们为你准备了一段精彩的音频片段。请在各大播客平台搜索“We Have Ways”。源氏假装没有看她，凝视着花园，但他却向她投去许多侧目。她是个什么样的人？如果他们目前的亲密关系能带来哪怕一点点吸引人的地方，
had brought out anything at all attractive. First, her seated height was unusual. She was obviously very long in the back. I knew it, he thought in despair. Next came the real disaster. Her nose. He noted it instantly. Long and lofty that nose was, slightly drooping towards the end, and with at the tip a blush of red. Oh, a real horror. In colour she was whiter than snow, in fact slightly bluish, and her forehead was strikingly broad although below it her face seemed to go on and on for an extraordinarily long way.
那该有多高兴啊，不过这只是愚蠢的希望。首先，她坐着时的高度很不寻常。她的背部显然非常长。我早就知道了，他绝望地想。接下来是真正的灾难。她的鼻子。他一眼就注意到了。那个鼻子又长又高，末端微微下垂，鼻尖还带着一抹红色。哦，真是个可怕的怪物。她的肤色比雪还要白，甚至略带一点青色，她的额头异常宽阔，尽管在其下方，她的脸似乎还极其漫长地向下延伸着。
She was thin to the point of being pitifully bony and even through her gown he could see the excruciating angularity of her shoulders. Why had he insisted on finding out what all of her looked like? At the same time though she made a sight so outlandish that he could not keep his eyes off her. Her face showed how cold she was and he felt sorry for her. So that is a very well known episode from The Tale of Genji, Murasaki's novel. Genji has been courting this woman for a very long time, a very arduous process. She lives in genteel poverty in a decayed and overgrown palace called the Hitachi Princess, she is. And finally, he's caught a glimpse and he's very disappointed with her nose, isn't he Tom? Very ungallant, I think, from Genji there.
她瘦得可怜，骨瘦如柴，甚至透过长袍都能看到她肩膀上极其痛苦的棱角。他当时为什么非要坚持弄清楚她全身到底长什么样呢？不过与此同时，她那副怪异的模样又让他无法将视线从她身上移开。她的脸显露出她有多冷，这让他对她感到怜悯。所以这是《源氏物语》中一个非常著名的情节，这是紫式部的小说。源氏追求这个女人已经很长时间了，这是一个非常艰辛的过程。她生活在一个破败杂乱的宫殿里，过着体面的贫困生活，她就是常陆宫。最后，他终于瞥了她一眼，对她的鼻子非常失望，不是吗，汤姆？我觉得源氏此举很不风度。
Yeah, so the nose of the Hitachi Princess is celebrated in Japanese culture, you know, kind of drawings of it for centuries and centuries. And I guess that this portrait of the Hitachi Princess is a counterpoint to say Shonigun's portrayal of aristocratic life in Heian Kyo as delightful, charming, exquisite, because she lives a completely miserable life. Her parents are dead, she has no living relatives, so she is lonely, isolated, I mean scared. She's a very nervous woman. She's so old fashioned that she wears a comb in her hair and Murasaki just thinks this is hilarious. And it's as you get, you know, she's not only, she doesn't know white, she looks blue. Everybody is freezing. Her servants
对，所以常陆宫的鼻子在日本文化中很有名，几个世纪以来都有各种关于它的画作。我想常陆宫的肖像与清少纳言将平安京的贵族生活描绘成令人愉快、迷人、精致的景象形成了对比，因为她过着极其悲惨的生活。她的父母双亡，没有在世的亲戚，所以她孤独、孤立，我的意思是她很害怕。她是一个非常神经质的女人。她极其古板，头上还插着梳子，紫式部觉得这简直滑稽透顶。而且正如你所知，她不仅看起来不是白色的，甚至显得有些发青。每个人都在瑟瑟发抖。她的仆人们
are all sat around her kind of shivering and chattering. And the princess herself is reduced to wearing furs from Siberia, which as everyone knows is the kind of thing that only a very old lady would do. Right. And so she's a fright, but Genji is sorry for her and anxious for her. And so he rescues her and installs her in his palace. And so in that sense, everything works out for the best. But is it perhaps the case that this glimpse that we have of this woman who is cold and lonely and
都坐在她周围，冻得瑟瑟发抖，牙齿打颤。这位公主本人甚至不得不穿来自西伯利亚的皮草，众所周知，这种事只有极老的老太太才会做。没错。所以她看起来像个怪物，但源氏很同情她，也为她感到担忧。于是他救了她，把她安置在自己的宫殿里。所以从这个意义上说，一切都有了最好的结果。但有没有可能，我们对这个寒冷、孤独且
scared is a reminder that there's another side to the life at court and it's not all calligraphy. And indeed, a life in Japan more generally is obviously not all calligraphy and kind of, you know, elegant witticisms. There is a frigidity to it as well, maybe. Yeah, and I think a darkness, a literal darkness as well, because if you're spending most of your time stuck behind a screen, the way that the architecture functions, you know, there's a good deal of shadow and then you stick up a screen. You're spending a lot of your time in a kind of twilight. And we know this from the tale of Genji because there's an episode where Genji goes in to seduce
害怕的女人的惊鸿一瞥，是在提醒我们，宫廷生活还有另一面，它并不全是书法。而且，更广泛地说，日本的生活显然也不全是书法和各种优雅的妙语连珠。其中可能也存在一种冷酷。是的，我认为还有黑暗，字面意义上的黑暗，因为如果你大部分时间都呆在屏风后面，这种建筑风格的运作方式是，你知道的，有很大一部分阴影，然后你再竖起屏风。你大部分时间都处在一种暮色之中。我们从《源氏物语》中就知道这一点，因为有一个情节是源氏进去想要诱惑
one woman and ends up accidentally seducing the Empress and getting her pregnant, which is a key moment in the novel and actually results in his exile. So it's dark, but also of course it's cold. And having just come back from a holiday in Japan and stayed in a traditional Japanese house while it was snowing. I mean, it really is cold and the kind of the style of architecture means that when an icy wind is whistling, you really feel it. And so that is why women in the Heian court are wearing the large numbers of layers that they are. But I think even with those layers, they're probably freezing a lot of the time.
一个女人，结果却不小心诱惑了皇后并让她怀了孕，这是小说中的一个关键时刻，实际上也导致了他的流放。所以这里面很黑暗，但当然也很冷。我刚刚结束了日本假期，在下雪的时候住在一个传统的日本房子里。我的意思是，那里真的很冷，这种建筑风格意味着当冰冷的风呼啸而过时，你真的能切身感受到。这就是为什么平安宫廷的女性要穿那么多层衣服。但我认为，即便穿着那么多层衣服，她们可能大部分时间也都在挨冻。
And so the reality of life probably for most women at the Heian court is that it's very cold, it's very dark, and it's pretty boring because you're not having men coming and calling on you most of the time. But I don't think that that means, say, that Sae Shonigan in the Pillow Book is lying when she portrays the Heian court as exquisite and delightful and charming. And in the translation that we've been quoting from, the Penguin Classic translated by Meredith McKinney, she places the Pillow Book in the context of a political crisis at court that was directly threatening Seishonigen's position there and the empress that she was serving. And so, Meredith McKinney describes the Pillow Book as a work that not
所以对于平安宫廷的大多数女性来说，现实生活可能非常寒冷、黑暗，而且相当无聊，因为大多数时候都没有男人来拜访你。但这并不意味着，清少纳言在《枕草子》中将平安宫廷描绘得精致、愉快、迷人是在说谎。在我们一直引用的译本中，也就是梅雷迪思·麦金尼翻译的企鹅经典版中，她将《枕草子》置于宫廷政治危机的背景下，这场危机直接威胁到了清少纳言在那里的地位以及她所侍奉的皇后。因此，梅雷迪思·麦金尼将《枕草子》描述为一部不仅坚决拒绝承认这些悲伤，而且在很大程度上拒绝承认悲伤本身的作品，它赋予我们的是一个充满精致愉悦的世界，这听起来可能是一个奇怪的类比，但我总是想起P.G.伍德沃斯在30年代笔下的伯蒂·伍斯特，这个充满温和幽默的世界实际上容不下大萧条或战争之类的事情，我认为《枕草子》也是如此。这是一种刻意不承认黑暗的决心。换句话说，一部高度精致且阳光的作品，其背后依托的是一个更加黑暗、冲突更多的背景。所以给我们讲讲这场宫廷危机吧，因为实际上我们一直在谈论的这两个人物，
only resolutely refuses to acknowledge these sorrows, but that largely refuses to acknowledge sorrow itself and gives us in its place a world of exquisite delight and it'll sound a weird parallel but I always thought of P.G. Woodhouse writing Bertie Worcester in the 30s that this world of kind of genial humour has no place really for depressions or wars or whatever and I think it's similar with the Pillow Book. It is a deliberate determination not to admit the darkness. So in other words, a work of great sophistication and sunniness depends on a context that is much darker and more conflicted. So tell us about this crisis at court, because actually the two characters we've been talking
一边是紫式部，另一边是清少纳言，她们处于这场略带《权力的游戏》风格的派系斗争的对立双方，对吧？是的，这在《源氏物语》的第一句话中就有所暗示，你在上一集中读过，大家可能还记得，它是这样开头的：“某个朝代，究竟会是哪个朝代呢？”这就引入了一个贯穿全书的主题，即天皇本人其实是匿名且被动的，他们总是被退位并由另一个人取代。他们没有任何真正的个性。这反映了一个事实，当桓武天皇——听过上一集的听众可能还记得——曾在一个叫奈良的国都，觉得作为天皇自己正受到日本大贵族阴影的笼罩，于是他离开并建立了平安京，试图恢复皇权。这表明这种努力并没有成功，在10世纪的进程中，随着平安京的建立，天皇的权力继续被剥夺，尽管他仍然是政府和国家的中心，但这已经不再具有任何积极意义。因此，他采用了中国“天皇”的称号，我们可以将其翻译为Emperor（皇帝），而“天皇”，我们在上一集中说过，意味着北极星。正如约书亚·弗里德曼在他关于日本神话的书中所说，北极星并不
about, Murasaki on one side and Seishonagun on the other, they are on opposite sides of this slightly Game of Thrones-ish factional battle, aren't they? Yeah, and it's hinted in the very first sentence of the Tale of Genji, which you read out in the previous episode, and people may remember it, it starts, In a certain reign, whose can it have been? And this introduces a theme that runs throughout the novel, which is that the figure of the emperor himself is kind of anonymous and passive, and they're always kind of being retired and replaced by another one. They have no real personality. And this reflects the fact that when the emperor Kanmu, people who listened to the last episode may remember that he had
做什么。它只是静静地坐在那里，凭借其自身的存在，其他一切都围绕着它旋转。理论上，天皇也是如此。他存在于政府的中心，万物都围绕着他运行，但他自己除了单纯地存在之外，什么都不需要做。”还有一个词用来指代天皇，也可以翻译为皇帝，那就是“御门”（Mikado），就像吉尔伯特和沙利文的歌剧一样。这有点像法老。所以“法老”字面意思就是大房子。它将统治者的形象与他所居住的建筑等同起来。而“御门”字面意思就是内宫之门。正是这些门把平民
been in a capital called Nara and had felt that he as emperor was coming under the shadow of the great lords of Japan and he had gone off and founded Heian Kyo in an attempt to restore imperial authority. What this suggests is that that effort hadn't worked, that over the course of the 10th century, following the foundation of Heian Kyo, the Emperor had continued to be leeched of his power and although he remains the center of the government and the state, it's not in kind of any active sense. So he has taken on the Chinese title Tennu, which we might translate it as Emperor, and Tennu, we said this in the previous episode, means the pole star. And as Joshua Friedman in his book on Japanese mythology puts it, the pole star does not
挡在外面，却把天皇关在里面。所以同样地，这是一种他被幽禁起来的想法。他就像是体制核心里的一个囚犯。是的，几乎是这样。当你今天去东京时，皇宫有这样一条令人惊叹的护城河，有这些巨大的墙壁，你直到今天都无法从外面看到里面，皇宫有这样一条惊人的护城河。它有这些大墙，你无法看到里面。我的意思是，天皇感觉像是一个非常隐形的中心，我想早在11世纪他就是这样了。所以如果天皇真的不是，你知道的，他不是一个专制君主，他
do anything. It simply sits and by virtue of what it is, everything else rotates around it. The Tenno is theoretically the same. He exists at the center of the government and all things orbit around him, but he himself does not need to do anything other than simply be." And there's another word that is applied to the emperor, which could be translated as emperor, which is micardo, as in the Gilbert and Sullivan opera. And this is a bit like pharaoh. So pharaoh means literally the great house. It's identifying the figure of the ruler with the architecture of where he lives. And Mikado literally means gates of the inner palace. And these are the gates that keep the people
没有在治理国家。是谁在治理国家？因为我们还没有进入将军时代，也就是那些伟大的军阀。武士和封建势力的竞争。那究竟是谁在掌权？在我们刚才谈论的那个时期，基本上是一个单一的家族，即藤原家族，他们历史非常悠久，声望极高。早在奈良时代各派混战的时候，他们就已经在那里了。他们一直是主要玩家，但到了10世纪中叶，他们
out but keep the emperor in. So again, it's this idea that he's being kind of closeted away. He's like a prisoner at the heart of the system. Yeah, almost. And when you go to Tokyo to this day, the palace, it has this amazing moat, it has these great walls you can't see inside to this day, the palace, it has this amazing mode. It has these great walls you can't see inside. I mean, the emperor feels kind of very invisible center, which I guess is what he is even back in the 11th century. So if the emperor's not really, you know, he's not an, he's not the autocrat, he's
实际上已经将自己确立为了宫廷的统治者，并通过延伸，成为了整个日本的统治者。他们做到这一点并不是靠耀武扬威（你知道的，他们并没有武士听命于他们，他们也不是伟大的军事领袖）。他们之所以能做到，是因为他们在政治和派系斗争方面极其精明，特别是日本历史学家所称的“婚姻政治”。婚姻政治的精髓就是让天皇娶你的女儿，这样你就能与坐在皇位上的人物建立姻亲关系。引用伊万·莫里斯的话来说，到了10世纪，藤原家族强加给天皇一种几乎
not running the state. Who is running the state? Because we're not yet in the age of the Shogun, you know, the great warlords. The samurai and the feudal rivalries. So who's in charge? At the time we've been talking about, it's basically a single family, the Fujiwara, and they are very ancient, very distinguished. They're even back in the time of Nara with all the faction fighting there. They had been kind of leading players, but by the middle of the 10th century, they've
注定要将他置于家族掌控之下的生命周期。他作为一个羽翼未丰的年轻人登上皇位，并立刻娶了一位藤原家的女孩。他们的儿子将被立为太子，当他的父亲被迫退位时（通常在30岁左右），这个太子就会继位，然后这个循环又会重新开始。因此，天皇根本没有办法摆脱藤原家族用婚姻枷锁禁锢他们的命运。而当清少纳言来到宫廷时，日本实际上的统治者是一个当时已经不是非官方、而是正式掌握权力的人。他是作为天皇的摄政王在统治。他通过将自己的女儿——一个名叫藤原定子的女性——嫁给年仅11岁的一条天皇，从而达成了这一点。所以非常非常容易被操纵。
effectively established themselves as the rulers of the court and therefore by extension, the whole of Japan. And they do this not by kind of throwing their weight around, you know, they don't have samurai at their beck and call, they're not great military leaders. They do it because they are brilliant at politics and at faction fighting and specifically at what Japanese historians call marriage politics. And the essence of marriage politics is to get the emperor married to your daughter so that you will be related by marriage to the figure who sits on the throne. So to quote Ivan Morris, by the 10th century, the Fujiwara's had imposed on the emperor a type of life cycle that was almost
而且一条天皇一直受制于道长（藤原道长），部分因为他还是个男孩，部分因为当时场景中有三位太上皇。他们都已经被退位退休了。这显然削弱了他的权威。我想部分也是因为他从小接受的教育就是永远不要反对藤原家族。他只是坐在他的宫殿里扮演他过去的那个角色，仅此而已。因此定子，他的妻子，也就是清少纳言所侍奉的皇后，正是那个让定子写下所有诗歌、并与她打赌关于雪之类事情的人。定子觉得定子（原文如此，应为道长对定子的评价，此处为上下文人名指代）很棒。她觉得她既有趣、聪明又时尚。而作为回报，清少纳言作为定子随从陪伴在她身边，极大地增加了定子的
bound to keep him under the family's thumb. He came to the throne as a callow youth and was promptly married to a Fujiwara girl. Their son would be appointed crown prince and when his father was obliged to abdicate, usually at the age of about 30, this crown prince would succeed him and the cycle would start again. So there's no way for the emperor to break free of the kind of marriage chains that the Fujiwara's are fettering them with. And the effective ruler of Japan when say Shonagun comes to court is a man who by now is not unofficial, it's formal. He is ruling as the regent for the emperor. And he's done this by marrying his daughter, who is a woman called Teishi, to the emperor Ichijo, who was only 11 years old. So very, very easy to be manipulated.
声望，因为清少纳言是那么有名，那么受人赞誉。但显然，这两位女性的地位都有些岌岌可危。我的意思是，她们俩对此都心知肚明，因为这取决于道长继续留在现场并掌握权力。而且我认为，尽管《枕草子》中阳光明媚、轻松愉快的基调相当一致，但清少纳言偶尔也会透露出她对此有所察觉的蛛丝马迹。这有点像伯蒂·伍斯特故事里的黑色短裤。这里
And Ichijo is always under Mitsutaka's thumb, partly because he's a boy, partly because there are three retired emperors on the scene. They've all been kind of retired off. So that dilutes his authority, obviously. And I think partly because he's raised and educated never to oppose the Fujiwara. He just sits in his palace and plays his former role and that's it. And so Tashi, his wife, she is the empress for whom she served and the one who got Tashi to write all his poems and had the bet with her about the snow and all that sort of thing. And Tashi thinks Tashi is great. She thinks she's funny, she's smart, she's stylish. And in exchange, the presence of Seishonagon at Tashi's side as part of her retinue adds greatly to Tashi's
有一点暗示着舞台背后的黑暗。所以有这样一个场景，清少纳言描述了藤原道长。她觉得他太棒了，看起来苗条而优雅，驻足整理他的礼仪之剑。然后她描述了道长的兄弟、大纳言道长（注：此处应为道长的弟弟道家/实资等人，原文为commissioner Michinaga，即道长本人或其弟，此处上下文为道长）不仅向他的兄弟鞠躬，而且跪倒在地。然后她去把她看到的这些告诉了定子，说，哦，太奇妙了，真是个美丽的场景。然后她写道：“当我不断向皇后提起大纳言道长——也就是弟弟——是如何向摄政王鞠躬时，她笑着取笑我，称他为‘你那个老掉牙的最爱’。如果她能
prestige because Seishonagon is that famous, that celebrated. But obviously the position of both women is kind of precarious. I mean, both of them are completely aware of this because it depends on Mishitaka remaining on the scene and keeping hold of power. And I think despite the pretty consistent tone of sunniness and lightness that you get in the Pillow Book, occasionally there's the odd hint from Saechonagin that she is aware of this. It's a little bit like the black shorts in Bertie Worcester. There's
活到见证他日后取得的伟大成就时，她就会意识到我发现他是如此令人印象深刻是多么正确。”所以她写作的时候，定子已经去世，道长已经取代了道隆成为了摄政王。这发生在……所以道隆死于995年。接下来发生的事情是，排在下一位的兄弟继承了道隆的位子，但在几天内就去世了，于是道长随后成为了摄政王。对于定子和清少纳言来说，这是非常糟糕的消息，因为很显然道长会想要把自己的女儿嫁给一条天皇。
a little hint of the darkness off stage. So there's a scene where Sae Shonigan describes Michi Taka. She thinks he's great, looking wonderfully slender and elegant, pausing to adjust his ceremonial sword. And then she describes how Michi Taka's brother, the commissioner Michi Naga, did not just bow before his brother but sank to his knees. And she goes and relates to Teishi what she's seen and says, oh, it's marvelous, such a beautiful scene. And then she writes, when I kept mentioning to her majesty how commissioner Michinaga, so the younger brother, had bowed before the region, she smilingly teased me by referring to him as that perennial favorite of yours. If she could
哦，对。好的。所以事实证明那是他的侄女，那是他的侄女，对吧？那还不够好。必须是他的女儿。他不会把定子做掉。他不会废掉她。但他要做的是，本质上确保有第二位皇后。所以将会有两位同等地位的皇后。但这显然极大地动摇了定子的地位。这发生在1000年。所以，道长有一个10岁的女儿叫彰子，她嫁给了一条天皇。现在有了两位皇后，也有了两个宫廷。而道长显然很了解清少纳言。他们一直都在
have lived to witness the greatness he later attained, she would have realized how right I was to find him so impressive. So she's writing at a time where Taishi has died and where Michinaga has replaced Michitaka as regent. And that happened in, so Michutaka died in 995. And what happens then is that the next brother in line succeeds Mitsutaka, dies within a few days and so Mitsunaga then becomes regent. And for Taishi and Seishonogun, this is very bad news because obviously Mitsunaga is going to want to marry one of his own daughters to the Emperor Ichijo.
开玩笑（原文重复了一句），清少纳言一直在谈论他在向他兄弟跪下时是多么出色之类的事情。他基本上希望他的女儿彰子也能有一位文学巨星作为女房（女官）。这就是紫式部登场的地方，因为她不仅因其学识和文学天才而闻名，而且她实际上自己也是藤原家族的一员，尽管来自该家族一个相当次要的分支。所以她太完美了。因此紫式部加入了进来，你可以看出为什么这会给这两个女人之间的竞争增添一个额外的维度。
Oh, right. Okay. So the fact that it's his niece, it's his niece, right? That's not good enough. It's got to be his daughter. He's not going to bump Tashi off. He's not going to set her aside. But what he is going to do is essentially ensure that there is a second empress. So there will be two empresses of equal rank. But this obviously destabilizes Teishi's position massively. And it happens in the year 1000. So, Michinaga has a 10-year-old daughter called Shoshi, and she gets married to the emperor. And there are now two empresses, and there are two courts. And Michinaga obviously knows Seishonogun well. They've been kind of bantering knows Seishonagun well, you know, they've been kind
结果证明，基本上是紫式部押对了赢家，因为在彰子被提升为与定子平起平坐的联合皇后（即嫁给一条天皇）几个月后，定子在产子时去世了。因此，现在所有的目光都聚焦在彰子身上。她能否为她的丈夫生下一个儿子，从而确保她父亲对权力的掌控？她结婚时只有10岁，过了8年她才终于怀孕。然后，巨大的紧张感再次出现：她能在分娩中存活下来吗？如果她活下来了，她能生下一个男孩吗？正是在这种紧张的氛围中，紫式部开始写她的日记。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的戏剧性时刻。因此
of bantering and Seishonagun has been going on about how brilliant he is when he kneels before his brother and all that kind of stuff. And he basically wants his daughter Shoshi to have a literary superstar as a lady in waiting as well. And this is where Murasaki Shikibu comes in, because she is not just celebrated for her learning and her literary genius, but she's actually a Fujiwara herself, albeit from quite a kind of minor branch of the family. So she's perfect. So Murasaki comes in and this, you can see why this would add an extra dimension to the rivalry between the two women.
她描述道：“皇后陛下听着她的女官们进行闲聊。”她一定有些苦恼。再次令人惊叹。这是一份关于……历史上和世界各地君主制中如此重要事件的记录。统治者的妻子会给这位统治者生一个儿子吗？在这里，你看到有史以来最伟大的作家之一以新闻记者的笔触记录下了这一切。是的，就好像它是实时发生的一样。重大剧透警告，彰子在分娩中幸存下来了，而且她确实生了一个儿子，这对于道长来说太棒了，因为他的权力基础现在稳固了。是的。因此，他稳稳地掌握着权力，直到1028年去世，没有人想过要挑战他。到他去世时，他已经做过两位天皇的内兄，一位天皇的舅舅，
And it's Murasaki, it turns out, basically, who has has backed the winning side because a few months after Shoshi has been promoted to the rank of joint empress alongside Tashi, so marrying Ichijo, Tashi dies in childbirth. And so all eyes now are on Shoshi. Will she be able to give her husband a son and thereby ensure her father's hold on power? She's only 10 when she marries, it's eight years before she finally gets pregnant. And then again, there's massive tension because will she survive childbirth? And if she does, will she deliver a boy? And it's amid this mood of tension that Murasaki begins her diary. I mean, it's incredibly dramatic moment. And
一条天皇的舅舅兼岳父（所以又是一位），以及另外两位天皇的祖父。所以我的意思是，他绝对处于皇宫权力的中心。对于清少纳言和紫式部来说，对于前者而言，定子的死宣告了她宫廷时光的结束。因此你可以看到，我认为《枕草子》的很大一部分一定是在她退休后写的，实际上，它几乎是在一种对逝去的深刻意识中写就的。如果它是一首对快乐的赞歌（它毫无疑问是），它是你能读到的最欢乐的书籍之一，我认为它同时也见证了快乐的稍纵即逝和虚无缥缈。紫式部，她似乎成了赢家。所以她最终与道长如此亲密，以至于在随后的几十年和几个世纪里，流传着各种牵强附会的传说，说她实际上与他有过一段恋情。我认为毫无疑问，源氏这个角色以及他走向伟大的崛起，某种程度上是以道长为原型的。而一条天皇，他喜欢故事，所以他喜欢《源氏物语》，很有可能正是这一点鼓励了紫式部把它写得这么长。当然，道长对此感到欣喜若狂，因为这加深了一条天皇对彰子（道长的女儿）的深情。所以你可以看到，文学并不是脱离权力政治的，而是绝对交织在其中的。
so she describes her majesty listens to her ladies in waiting engaged in idle gossip. She must be in some distress. Again, amazing. It's an account of, you know, an event that is so important in monarchies throughout history and across the world. Will the wife of a ruler give that ruler a son? And here you have one of the greatest writers of all time describing it in journalistic fashion. Yeah, as though it's in real time. And big spoiler alert, Shoshi does survive childbirth and she does have a son, which is brilliant for Michinaga because his power base is now secure. Yeah. And so he stays securely in power until he dies in 1028 and no one thinks to challenge him. And by the time he dies, he has been brother-in-law to two emperors, uncle to one,
是的。你知道的，这会让紫式部快乐吗？我不认为她是一个特别快乐的人，比起清少纳言在日记中那样，但在《源氏物语》中更是如此，而且更有力得多。快乐的稍纵即逝，以及在回忆快乐时刻时感到的痛苦，可以说是她最伟大的主题之一。书中后来有一个著名的场景，对吧？当源氏相遇时，他这个时候已经老了，他遇到了一个他曾爱慕多年的女人，他给她写了一首诗，非常符合那种……除了我们两个，谁还知道所有这一切是如何把我们带到这里的，所以也可以向住吉的松树诉说，它们见证了神明自己的时间。那么这借鉴了什么呢，汤姆？嗯，这些诗句，我想，借鉴了日本某种原始信仰，即神道教信仰。所以你有那些极其古老的松树，就像自然界的许多事物一样，无论是河流、高山还是其他什么，它们必定被视为神圣。你有神明自己的时间，这等同于永恒，因此你有一种感觉，爱本身可以战胜时间。
uncle and father-in-law to Ichijo, so that's another one, and grandfather to two more emperors. So I mean, he is absolutely at the center of power in the Imperial Palace. For say Shonigan and Murasaki Shikibu, for the former, the death of Tashi spells the end of her time at court. And so you can see, I think therefore that the pillow book, much of which she must have written in retirement, Actually, it is written with a real consciousness of bereavement almost. And if it's a eulogy to joy, which it undoubtedly is, it's one of the most joyous books you could possibly read. I think it is also testimony to the fleeting nature, the insubstantiality of joy. Murasaki, she seems to have come out as a winner. So she ends up so close
但问题是，甚至在源氏创作这些诗句的时候，他内心其实并不相信这一点。原因在于，我们一直在描述的中国文化的种种表现形式——写作、诗歌、时尚、歌曲、舞蹈、政府的标准，并不是那几个世纪里“中国狂热症”的唯一遗产，因为——我们还没有真正触及神圣领域——中国文化还有另一个方面在日本得到了极大程度的发展，那就是佛教。你说是神圣的领域，汤姆，但他们不会有……这个词对他们来说有点毫无意义。宗教这个概念本身就会毫无意义，因为在日本，世俗与宗教之间没有区别。
to Michinaga that there are all kinds of far-fetched stories told in the decades and centuries that follow that she'd actually had a relationship with him. I think there's no doubt that Genji as a character and his rise to greatness is kind of modeled a bit on Michinaga. And Ichijo, he loves stories and so he loves the tale of Genji and it may well be that it's this that encourages Murasaki to write it at the length that she does. And of course, Michinaga is delighted about this because it intensifies Ichijo's devotion to Shoshi, to Mitsunaga's daughter. So you can see the way in which literature isn't at a remove from power politics, but is absolutely kind of woven into it.
天哪，我听起来越来越像汤姆·霍兰德了。你听起来确实像我。是的，你完全正确。但为了找不到更好的词，我们暂且称之为佛教吧。它大约在公元6世纪传入日本，并在8世纪的奈良蓬勃发展。奈良拥有最美妙的佛教寺庙和令人惊叹的雕像。我的意思是，你正准备去日本，对吧？我想这会震撼人们的心灵。我实际上要住在日本的一座佛教寺庙里。你要去奈良吗？我要去奈良。它不在奈良。它在圣山高野山，那是神圣的佛教圣山。现在我知道这不是公众形象的一部分。
Yeah. You know, does this make Murasaki happy? I don't think she's a particularly happy person and much more readily than say Shonagun isigan is in her diary, but even more so and more powerfully in the tale of Genji. The fleeting nature of joy and the pain that you can feel in recalling moments of joy is kind of one of her great themes. There's a famous scene isn't there later in the book when Genji meets, he's old at this
所以我讨厌告诉人们这一点，但我们播客的公众形象并不代表我们的全部个性。这其实也很“白莲花”。是的。好吧，是的，我希望不会有“白莲花”风格。所以奈良是一个伟大的佛教城市，这也是首都之所以要迁址的原因之一，因为那里的僧侣拥有如此巨大的权力，以至于天皇感到了他们投下的阴影。到了9世纪，进入10和11世纪，本土传统与佛教传统开始融合，创造出了一种具有决定性日本特色的佛教形式。这在平安京随处可见。
point, he meets a woman that he'd been in love with for many years and he writes her a poem, very sort of, who else but we two knows all that has brought us here and so may address the pines of Sumiyoshi witness to the God's own time. So what does that draw on Tom? Well, they're lines that are drawing, I guess, on the kind of the primal beliefs of Japan, the Shinto beliefs. So you have pines that are so ancient that like so much of the natural world, whether it's rivers or mountains or whatever, that they must be held divine. You have the God's own time, which equates to eternity, and therefore you have a sense that love itself can cheat time.
所以那口寺庙的钟，当清少纳言缩在被窝里时听到它在深夜响起，那是一口佛教的钟。而紫式部在描述皇后彰子准备产子时，她听到，她描述听到永无休止地诵经的声音，那是佛教僧侣的声音。还有一个叫宇治的小镇，位于平安京以南大约10英里处，《源氏物语》的最终章就以那里为背景。道长在那里买了一座别墅，后来被他的儿子改建为一座宏伟的佛教寺庙。这座寺庙出现在日本的硬币之一上，里面保存着平安时代少数幸存的杰作之一，即这尊巨大的木制佛像。所以佛教是平安京绝对基础的一部分，是那个时代伟大作家所描述的世界的一部分。但如果你仔细想想，你之前提到了神道教。这些并不是竞争性的宗教，就像我们认为的基督教与伊斯兰教，或者基督教与异教那样，对吧？它们，即使在今天，许多日本人在被问到“你信仰神道教还是你是佛教徒？”时也会感到纠结。
But the thing is that even as Genji is composing these lines, he doesn't actually in his heart believe it. And the reason for that is that all the manifestations of Chinese culture that we've been describing, the writing, the poetry, the fashions, the song, the dance, the stars of government, these are not the only legacy of that kind of, you know, those centuries of Sinomania because, and we haven't yet touched really on the sacral, there is another aspect of Chinese culture which takes off in Japan to a momentous degree and that is Buddhism. Will you say the sacral Tom, but they wouldn't have the, that word would be slightly meaningless to them. It would be just the very idea of religion would be meaningless because there's no distinction
因为他们不理解那种你会完全挑选和选择不同信仰体系的概念。是的，我的意思是，写了那么多关于基督教及其在古代和异教古代的兴起的文章后，日本的佛教与之形成了鲜明的对比。因此，虽然基督教驱逐了地中海的古代神祇，但这并没有在日本发生。我的意思是，确实存在紧张关系。本土传统的某些元素确实反对佛教的引入，但它们并没有被驱赶出去。所以在紫式部和清少纳言的时代，天皇（正如今天的天皇一样）仍然声称自己是太阳女神的后裔。他那纯洁的女儿将作为太阳女官（斋宫）来服务
between the secular and the religious in Japan. God almighty, I'm sounding like Tom Holland. You are sounding like me. Yes, you are absolutely right. But let's call it Buddhism for want of a better word. And it arrives in Japan, probably in the sixth century, it flourishes at Nara in the eighth century. Nara's boasts the most wonderful Buddhist temples, astonishing statues. I mean, you're just about to go to Japan, aren't you? I think this will blow people's minds. I'm actually going to stay in a Buddhist monastery in Japan. Are you going to Nara? I'm going to Nara. It's not in Mara. It's on Mount Coya, which is the sacred Buddhist mountain. Now I know this is not part of the persona.
在日本，世俗与宗教之间的关系。天哪，我听起来越来越像汤姆·霍兰了。你听起来确实像我。是的，你完全说得对。但为了方便起见，我们暂且称之为佛教吧。它大约在六世纪传入日本，并在八世纪的奈良繁荣发展。奈良拥有最美妙的佛教寺庙和令人惊叹的雕塑。我的意思是，你正准备去日本，对吧？我想这会让人大开眼界。我实际上打算在日本的一座佛教寺庙里过夜。你要去奈良吗？我要去奈良。它不在奈良。它在高野山上，那是一座神圣的佛教山。现在我知道这不是我平时人设的一部分了。
And so I hate to tell people this, but our podcast personas are not our entire personality. It's quite quite white Lotus as well. Yeah. Well, yeah, I hope there won't be white Lotus style. So Nara is a kind of great Buddhist city and that's one of the reasons actually why why the capital gets moved is because the the monks there are wielding such power that the emperor is feeling in their shadow as well. And by the ninth century going into the 10th and 11th century, native and Buddhist traditions are kind of merging to create a definitively Japanese form of Buddhism. And this is manifest
因此，我很讨厌告诉大家这一点，但我们的播客人设并不代表我们的全部个性。这也相当有《白莲花度假村》的风格。是的。好吧，是的，我希望不会出现白莲花那样的风格。所以奈良是一个伟大的佛教城市，这也是首都之所以搬迁的原因之一，因为那里的僧侣掌握着巨大的权力，让皇帝感到了他们的阴影。到了九世纪，进入十世纪和十一世纪，本土传统与佛教传统开始融合，创造出一种明确具有日本特色的佛教形式。这一点体现在
everywhere in Heian Kyo. So that temple bell, which say Shonagun hears ringing in the dead of night when she's tucked up under her bedclothes, that's a Buddhist bell. And Murasaki, when she's describing how the emperor Soshi is preparing to give birth to her child, she hears, she describes hearing voices in ceaseless recitation of sutras, which are the voices of Buddhist monks. And there is a town called Uji, which is about 10 miles south of Peiyankyo, where the final chapters of the Tale of Genji is set. And Michinaga buys a villa there, which is then converted by his son into a great Buddhist temple. This temple appears on one of the Japanese coins and it contains what is one of the few surviving masterpieces
平安京的各个角落。所以，清少纳言在深夜躲在被窝里听到的那记悠扬的寺庙钟声，就是佛教的钟声。而紫式部在描述彰子皇后如何准备生孩子时，她听到并描述了无数诵经声，那是佛教僧侣的声音。在平安京以南大约10英里处有一个叫宇治的小镇，《源氏物语》的最后几章就是以那里为背景的。道长在那里买了一栋别墅，后来被他的儿子改建为一座宏伟的佛教寺庙。这座寺庙出现在了一枚日本硬币上，里面保存着为数不多的幸存杰作之一
of Heian art, which is this colossal wooden sculpture of the Buddha. So Buddhism is an absolutely fundamental part of Heian Kyo, this world described by the great writers of the period. But if you think of it, you mentioned Shinto before. These are not competing religions in the sense that we would think of Christianity and Islam or Christianity and paganism, right? They are, even today, lots of Japanese people struggle when they're asked, do you believe in Shintoism or are you a Buddhist?
即平安时代的艺术瑰宝，一座巨大的佛陀木雕。因此，佛教是平安京绝对核心的一部分，是这一时期伟大作家笔下所描绘的世界。但如果你仔细想想，你刚才提到了神道教。这并不是像我们所理解的基督教与伊斯兰教，或者基督教与异教那种相互竞争的宗教，对吧？即使在今天，许多日本人在被问到“你信仰神道教还是佛教？”时，也会感到困惑
Because they don't understand the concept that you would be picking and choosing different belief systems entirely. Yeah, I mean, it's really striking having written so much about Christianity and its emergence in antiquity and pagan antiquity. Buddhism in Japan is such contrast. So whereas Christianity banishes the ancient gods of the Mediterranean, that doesn't happen in Japan. I mean, there are definitely tensions. There are elements of the kind of the native traditions that really oppose the introduction of Buddhism, but they are not driven out. So in the time of Murasaki and say Shonigan, the emperor, as the emperor today does, is still claiming descent from the sun goddess. His virgin daughter will be serving as the sun
因为他们无法理解必须在不同的信仰体系之间做出完全排他选择的概念。是的，我的意思是，写了那么多关于基督教及其在古代和异教古代兴起的历史后，这种对比真的非常鲜明。基督教驱逐了地中海的古代神祇，但在日本并没有发生这种情况。我的意思是，确实存在紧张关系。本土传统中确实有一些元素强烈反对佛教的引入，但在当时并没有被彻底驱逐。因此，在紫式部和清少纳言的时代，正如今天的日本天皇一样，皇帝仍然宣称自己是太阳神的后裔。他未出阁的女儿也将继续担任太阳女神的祭司
goddess's priestess in what is the greatest shrine in Japan. And you still have this sense that the divine is imminent in the natural world that was evident in that poem that Genji writes. But Buddhism, although it is able to coexist with these beliefs, it does teach that the gods worshipped in these various shrines or whatever are themselves part of the illusory world, along with the beauties of the natural world, love the world itself, in fact. And this is what everybody that we've been talking about in this episode and the previous episode believes. So Shane O'Gon does. And it said, we don't know with what reliability, but it's
作为日本最伟大神社里女神的女祭司。你依然能感受到那种在自然界中神明仿佛触手可及的感觉，正如源氏所写的那首诗中所表现的那样。但佛教，尽管它能够与这些信仰共存，但它确实教导说，这些不同神社中崇拜的神灵本身，连同自然界的美景、爱情以及世界本身，其实都是虚幻世界的一部分。事实上，我们在本集和上一集里谈到的每个人都是这么认为的。所以中宫生（Shonagon）也是如此。据说——虽然我们不知道这有多可靠，但它
often repeated that at the end of her life, she follows the example of what lots of other people at court, including emperors do, which is to renounce the world. And she throws away her beautiful clothes and she shaves off her beautiful hair and she becomes a nun. And this is something that Murasaki we know was very tempted by, because she feels dread that as a woman she is fated not to attain enlightenment, that she's bound to be reborn, that she'll have to be reborn as a man before she can have any prospect of enlightenment. And she writes about, I think, very painfully and movingly, someone with as much to atone for as myself may not qualify for salvation. There are so many things that serve to remind one of the transgressions of a former existence. Everything conspires to make me unhappy. And I think it's that capacity to worry that everything that is beautiful and
经常被提起的是，在她生命的尽头，她效仿了宫廷中许多其他人（包括天皇）的做法，也就是出家遁入空门。她丢下了美丽的衣裳，剃去了美丽的青丝，成了一名尼姑。我们知道，紫式部对此曾感到非常诱惑，因为她感到一种恐惧：作为一个女人，她注定无法获得觉悟，她注定会轮回，在有任何觉悟的可能之前，她必须先转世为一个男人。她写道，我想这非常痛苦和感人：“像我这样有那么多罪孽需要赎罪的人，可能没有资格获得拯救。有太多事情让人想起前世的过犯。一切都在密谋让我痛苦。”我想正是这种担忧的能力——担忧一切美丽的事物和
a cause of happiness is itself an illusion that gives the tale of Genji its distinctive character. That it expresses such love for the beauties and joys of the moment, but also such a sense of sorrow that these beauties and joys will ultimately vanish. And in fact, you have to reject them if you are going to attain the eternal beauty and joy of enlightenment. And so, Murasaki, she says, I want to give it all up. I want to become a nun, but she also dreads it. And she writes, supposing I were to commit myself and turn my back on the world. I am certain there would be moments of irresolution before Amida came for me riding on his clouds. So who is, uh, who is Amida?
作为幸福之源的事物本身就是一个幻象——赋予了《源氏物语》其独特的性格。它表达了对当下的美丽和快乐的无限热爱，但也流露出一种深深的悲伤，即这些美丽和快乐终将消逝。事实上，如果你想获得觉悟的永恒之美与快乐，你必须拒绝它们。因此，紫式部说，我想放弃这一切。我想成为一名尼姑，但她同时也对此感到恐惧。她写道：“假设我真的下定决心，背弃这个世界。我确信，在阿弥陀佛驾着祥云来接我之前，一定会出现动摇的时刻。”那么，谁是，呃，谁是阿弥陀佛？
Is he a, he's a version of the Buddha. Is that right? So he is a Buddha. He is the Buddha to whom the Heyang Korti has seen particularly to have prayed. So in, in Uji, this great temple, the great statue carved out of wood and gilded there is Amida. And the appeal of Amida, I think there are two aspects to it. The first is that he seems to promise enlightenment to everyone. So this is why he's particularly popular with women. He seems to offer the promise to women that they don't have to be reborn necessarily. But also he
他是，他是佛陀的一个版本吗？是的，所以他是一尊佛。他是平安京的宫廷似乎特别向其祈祷的佛陀。因此，在宇治，这座伟大的寺庙里，那尊从木头中雕刻出来并镀金的巨大雕像就是阿弥陀佛。阿弥陀佛的吸引力，我认为有两个方面。首先，他似乎向所有人承诺觉悟。所以这就是为什么他在女性中特别受欢迎。他似乎向女性提供了一个承诺，即她们不一定非得转世。但他也
seems to promise that love can survive death because what he is supposed to have done is that when he attained enlightenment, the Amida Buddha creates a paradise in the uttermost West and that people who pray to him for salvation can attain this paradise, this Western pure land, and they will be reborn there and they will live in this paradise that precious metals are living, jewels grow from the ground and people themselves when they are born there emerge from lotuses into eternal light. They're free from any sort of sin and though in due course they will die, then they will attain enlightenment. So it's a kind of, it's a final stage, a beautiful final stage before finally attaining the enlightenment that is the desire of every Buddhist. And this is the paradise that Murasaki believes could be hers, right?
似乎承诺爱情可以超越死亡，因为他被认为做过的事是：当他获得觉悟时，阿弥陀佛在极乐西方创造了一个净土，那些向他祈求拯救的人可以到达这个天堂，这个西方净土，他们将在那里再生，并生活在这个天堂里。在那里，贵金属是活的，珠宝从地里长出来，人们生于其中时，会从莲花中涌出，进入永恒的光明。他们摆脱了任何形式的罪恶，尽管在适当的时候他们会死去，但随后他们将获得觉悟。所以这是一种过渡，是一个美丽的最终阶段，然后才能最终获得每个佛教徒所渴望的觉悟。这就是紫式部相信会属于她的天堂，对吧？
Yes, and Genji, and they hope that they will meet and be able to renew their love there. So on her deathbed, Murasaki mourns that she would go alone into the unknown and the thought filled her with great sorrow. But she has consolation from the thought that in due cause Genji will be able to join her, and Genji tells her that one day we will share one lotus throne in the life to come. That is the hope that he cleaves to, even while he's shadowed by anxiety that of course he may not attain it. And so this sense of the yearning for things that have gone, a sense that things that go must go, a sense that everything is insubstantial, an awareness that time is a kind of treacherous dimension, all these things that kind of echo great modern European writers, Proust and
是的，还有源氏，他们希望在那里重逢并能够延续他们的爱情。因此，在临终前，紫式部哀叹自己将独自走向未知，这种想法让她充满了巨大的悲伤。但她从这样一个想法中得到了安慰：在适当的时候，源氏将能够与她团聚，源氏告诉她：“终有一天，在来世，我们将同享一个莲花宝座。”那是他紧紧抓住的希望，尽管他的内心阴影重重，焦虑着自己当然可能无法实现它。因此，这种对逝去之物的渴望感，一种认为逝去之物必将逝去的感知，一种认为一切皆为空幻的意识，一种意识到时间是一种诡谲维度的觉察——所有这些都带有一种回响，让人联想到伟大的现代欧洲作家，比如普鲁斯特
so on. I mean, they derive from the context of Murasaki, from the very specific cultural context in which he is born, lives and dies as you would expect. Right. Well, I mean, I can't recommend The Pillow Book too highly. I loved reading it. I think it's an extraordinary work of literature. And I think what's so joyous about it is not just that you can read it in and of itself as a, as a, as a, just a brilliantly entertaining book, but you could hardly find a better window into the world, this sort of incredibly alien and to us very strange world of, of early medieval Japan. So, I mean, you loved this, didn't you, Tom?
等等。我的意思是，它们源于紫式部的语境，源于她出生、生活和死去的那个非常具体的文化语境，正如你所料。对。我的意思是，我对《枕草子》的推荐简直无以复加。我非常喜欢读它。我认为这是一部非凡的文学作品。我认为它最让人快乐的地方不仅在于你可以将它本身作为一本精妙绝伦、极具娱乐性的书来读，而且你很难找到一扇更好的窗户来窥探那个世界——这个对我们来说极其陌生、非常奇特的中世纪早期日本世界。所以，我的意思是，你很喜欢这个，对吧，汤姆？
You would never, it's like Trafalgar. It's like something you just, you were sucked into this black hole. Yeah, I did. One of the additional reasons why I've so enjoyed doing the series is, as we said earlier, I cannot think of a greater contrast to the six-part epic that you are going to be leading directly after this, which is on Peter the Great. Yes. If you enjoy battles, the Great Northern War, the rise of Russia and the decline of the Swedish Empire, dwarfs being baked in pies, people having bellows inserted into
你永远不会，这就像特拉法加海战。就像你被吸进了一个黑洞一样。是的，我的确很喜欢。我如此享受制作这个系列节目的另一个原因，正如我们之前所说，我想不出有什么能与你紧接着要主持的那个六集史诗产生更鲜明的对比了，那个系列讲的是彼得大帝。是的。如果你喜欢战斗、大北方战争、俄罗斯的崛起和瑞典帝国的衰落、把侏儒烤进馅饼里、把风箱插入
them, Peter the Great going on holiday to the Dutch Republic and to England in disguise. If you like the sound of all that, you can hear all six parts on Monday by signing up to the Rest is History club at therestishistory.com. And if you do that, Tom, you will be welcomed into an Imperial court of almost unparalleled beauty and sophistication. That's right, isn't it? Oh, so beautiful. So sophisticated.
他们的身体里、彼得大帝化装去荷兰共和国和英国度假。如果你觉得这一切听起来很吸引人，你可以在周一通过注册 therestishistory.com 上的“历史其余部分”俱乐部来收听所有六集。如果你那样做了，汤姆，你将被迎入一个无与伦比的美丽和精致的帝国宫廷。对吧？哦，太美了。太精致了。
Right. Well on that characteristically humble note, I will say arigato, Tom and sayonara. Say. Yeah. Well, on that characteristically humble note, I will say, arigato, Tom, and sayonara. Sayonara. Here's the clip we mentioned earlier. Hope you enjoy. But there's these absolutely incredible personal stories right in the heart of it. And I think this is what's so amazing about the second world war. Yes, it's a titanic event and it's the tectonic plates of history colliding and all those
好吧，带着这种特有的谦逊态度，我要说阿里加托（谢谢），汤姆，还有再见（Sayonara）。说吧。是的。好吧，带着这种特有的谦逊态度，我要说：阿里加托，汤姆，还有再见。再见。这是我们之前提到的片段。希望你喜欢。但其中有着绝对不可思议的个人故事，就藏在它的核心。我想这正是第二次世界大战如此神奇的地方。是的，这是一场惊天动地的事件，是历史的构造板块在碰撞，还有所有那些
sort of things. But in it, there's the most amazing things that happen to individuals. Yes. And I think it's important that we don't lose sight of that. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. And I think it's important that we don't lose sight of that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Elena Kargans story is absolutely incredible. So she's a 25 year old interpreter attached to third shock army. She's drafted as a music.
诸如此类的事情。但在这其中，发生了发生在大人物身上的最惊人的事情。是的。我认为重要的是我们不能忽视这一点。是的。是的。是的。我认为重要的是我们不能忽视这一点。是的。是的。是的。叶莲娜·卡尔甘（Elena Kargan）的故事绝对令人难以置信。所以她是一个25岁的翻译，隶属于第三突击集团军。她被征召为音乐。
She wants to go to the front. She's drafted as a munitions worker, then trained as a nurse. And this reminds me of the women of SOEs. Someone spots that she can speak German. That's a really good point. And she's been interrogating prisoners, looking at captured documents, you know, it's finally work incredibly fulfilling. You're witnessing history, aren't you? You know, you're-
她想去前线。她先是被征召为军火工人，然后接受了护士培训。这让我想起了特别行动执行处（SOE）的女性。有人发现她会说德语。这真是个好点子。她一直在审讯战犯，查看缴获的文件，你知道的，这最终是一项极其充实的工作。你正在见证历史，不是吗？你知道，你——
Well, you know what's going on. I mean, that's the other thing. No one knows what's going on. She crosses into Germany at a checkpoint with a large roughly constructed archway and sign that says this was the German border. There's fires and summer smalls, summer larger. No effort to put them out because there's no water. You can't. Basically, she says it was very difficult to find your way through the city. Map reading because the run out of Russian signs and the German ones are mostly disappeared along with the walls.
好吧，你知道发生了什么。我的意思是，那是另一回事。没有人知道发生了什么。她在一个带有大型粗糙拱门和写着“这里是德国边境”标志的检查站进入德国。到处都是大大小小的火灾。没有人试图扑灭它们，因为没有水。你做不到。基本上，她说在城市里找路非常困难。看地图很痛苦，因为俄文路标用完了，德国路标大多连同墙壁一起消失了。
They push on. Streets become increasingly deserted as they close, they get to the government district. Case of bullets zipping and hissing by, more walls and buildings crashing around, they reach pots down the platz and then they kind of set themselves up in a basement of a house owned by a tailor and his family and begin the process of interrogating squealers in inverted commas. So these are captured prisoners. She says, you know, we were interested in just one thing. Where was Hitler? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们继续前进。随着他们不断靠近，街道变得越来越荒凉，他们到达了政府区。子弹在身旁呼啸而过，更多的墙壁和建筑在周围坍塌，他们到达了波茨坦广场，然后他们在一家由裁缝及其家人拥有的房子的地下室里安顿下来，开始审讯那些被加上引号的“告密者”。也就是被俘的战犯。她说，你知道，我们只对一件事感兴趣：希特勒在哪里？本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。